आई थिंक आई एम लाइव ओके आई थिंक वी आर गुड
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके या वी आर लाइव नाउ
हेलो एवरीबॉडी
नमस्ते गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू
नमस्ते नमस्ते एंड गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू
हां जी भैया नमस्ते नमस्ते नमस्ते टू
एवरीबॉडी गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
गुड इवनिंग
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके
ओके गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते।
सभी लोग को आ जाने देते हैं एक बार। सभी
लोग को ज्वाइन करने देते हैं क्योंकि आज
की जो सेशन है वह काफी धमाकेदार होने वाली
है। काफी इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाली है। काफी
टाइम से आप लोग वेट कर रहे थे इस सेशन का।
अ हां डेमोंस्ट्रेशन ही होगा आज साइबर
जैन। सब कुछ डेमोंस्ट्रेशन ही मोस्टली
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन ही होगा आपको। दिखाऊंगा मैं
सारी चीजें। नमस्ते। इस क्लास का वेट काफी
टाइम से आप लोग कर रहे थे। अह स्प्लunk का
जो कि एक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एसआईएम
सॉल्यूशन है। काफी वाइडली यूज़्ड एंड
इनफैक्ट यू कैन से एक लीडिंग एसआईएम
सॉल्यूशन है जो काफी सारी जो एंटरप्राइज
ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस है वो यूज करती है। राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़] सो विल बी स्टार्टिंग
वेरी वेरी सून नाउ।
क्योंकि क्योंकि आज का जो सेशन है वह
ज्यादातर डेमोंस्ट्रेशन से
भरा हुआ होने वाला है। एंड अ थ्योरी थोड़ी
कम है। थ्यरी थोड़ी सी कम है। अ एंड
प्रैक्टिकल ओरिएंटेड है आज की क्लास। तो
आज आपको मजा आने वाला है। एंड एसआईएम
सॉल्यूशन की बात करें तो स्प्लंक के अलावा
बहुत सारे एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन है। राइट? अ
सेंटिनल है आपका उसके बाद आपका वाजू है
ओपन सोर्स की बात करें तो बट स्प्लंक
वाइडली यूज्ड एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन है। सो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आई विल बी शोइंग यू दैट पर्टिकुलर थिंग्स।
ठीक है?
देखो
हम खुद का भी बना सकते हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है। वाजू को हम खुद का बना के खुद का
वाजू सेटअप कर सकते हैं। फ्री ओपन सोर्स
है एंड यू कैन डिप्लॉय दैट। बट अ मुझे
लगता है कि आपको पहले सीखना चाहिए कि
एक्सैक्टली काम कैसे करती है ये चीजें।
राइट? आप जॉब पे जब जाएंगे जॉब के लिए एज
एन एसओसी वन तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
वहां से आपको वहां आपको स्प्लंक वहां मतलब
आपको लोकल होस्ट पे वर्चुअल मशीन में
सेटअप नहीं कराया जाएगा। एसओसी की कोई भी
सॉफ्टवेयर को आपसे वर्चुअल मशीन के अंदर
सेटअप नहीं कराया जाएगा। आपको ऑलरेडी एक
सेटअप मिल जाएगा। या तो अगर ज्यादा से
ज्यादा आपको इंस्टॉलेशन करनी होगी तो वो
इंस्टॉलेशन कॉन्फ़िगरेशन कर पाएंगे।
मोस्टली चीजें आपको वहां पे परफॉर्म करनी
होती है। आपको अटैक्स को जो है ना जो
अलर्ट्स हैं उसको असाइन करना है। उसको
ट्रैक करना है। उसको एस्केलेट करना है। ये
सब आपके काम होते हैं। ठीक है? तो वो
चीजें हम सीखेंगे। हम बेकार की फालतू
चीजें नहीं सीखने वाले हैं जिसका कोई मतलब
नहीं बनता है। ठीक है? तो जैसे-जैसे मैं
बता रहा हूं जस्ट गो विद द फ्लो। ठीक है?
दैट्स इट। [हंसी]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
वाई स्प्लंक? व्हाई नॉट टूल्स लाइक वाजू।
अब मैं वाजू बताता तो आप लोग पूछते व्हाई
नॉट स्प्लंक? व्हाई वाजू? सिंपल सा फंडा
है। व्हाई स्प्ल? इसका एक ही रीज़न है।
स्प्लंक इज द मोस्ट वाइडली यूज्ड एसआईएम
सॉल्यूशन एंड सबसे ज्यादा यूज़ जो होता है
वो ये टूल है। ये एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन है
स्प्लक जो कि कंपनी के द्वारा यूज़ की जाती
है। ठीक है? तो बिफोर वी विल स्टार्ट
सर फीफा वर्ल्ड कप में किसको सपोर्ट करते
हैं? मैं फीफा वर्ल्ड कप क्या मैं फुटबॉल
ही नहीं देखता भाई। कोई सा भी वर्ल्ड कप
हो फुटबॉल का। आई डोंट वाच। इंटरेस्ट नहीं
है फीफा वर्ल्ड कप या फुटबॉल के मैचेस
में। चलिए वैसे मैं रोनाल्डो और मेसी का
फैन हूं। दोनों का ही फैन हूं मैं। दोनों
को ही पसंद करता हूं। ठीक है?
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] चलिए
सो एवरीबॉडी बिफोर वी स्टार्ट आई वुड
रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी कि आज फोकस थोड़ा
ज्यादा बना के रखिएगा क्योंकि आज हम बहुत
सारी चीजें करने वाले हैं। और सबसे पहली
चीज क्या करेंगे? तो हम इस प्लंक को
डाउनलोड भी करेंगे। इस प्लंक को इंस्टॉल
भी करेंगे, सेटअप करेंगे, सब कुछ करेंगे।
तो एकदम बिंदास होके रेडी हो जाइए। एंड
देयर आर लॉट ऑफ़ थिंग्स दैट वी आर गोइंग टू
डू टुडे। चलिए स्टार्ट तो कर देंगे।
स्टार्ट करने से पहले जैसा मैं बताता हूं
आपको कि YouTube पे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च
करेंगे आप। डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी का हमारा
YouTube का चैनल मिल जाता है। आपको सबसे
पहला काम क्या करना है? जब भी आप वीडियो
को देख रहे हैं, इसके लाइव सेक्शन में
जाना है और एसओसी की पहले की कोई भी
क्लासेस की वीडियो को उठा लीजिए। ठीक है?
लाइक एनी जैसे कोई भी एसओसी की क्लास है
जैसे ये 27 मैंने इसको ओपन किया इन अब
यहां पे इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में चले जाइए
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको दो लिंक्स मिलेंगे
एक WhatsApp चैनल का और एक WhatsApp ग्रुप
का दोनों को ओपन कर लीजिए सबसे पहले आपको
यही काम करना है WhatsApp चैनल को फॉलो कर
लीजिए लगभग 13000 से भी ज्यादा लोग हमारे
से जुड़े हैं क्योंकि हमारे साइट से जो भी
अपडेट्स आती है ना वो सबसे पहले इसी चैनल
पे आती है सबसे पहले मतलब फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट
से ज्वाइन करना कोई फॉलो करना है फ्री कोई
पैसा नहीं लगेगा। फॉलो कर लीजिएगा इसको।
एक WhatsApp [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ग्रुप है जो स्पेशली
एसओसी के लिए बनी है आपकी इस पर्टिकुलर
सीरीज के लिए। यहां पे ही आपको जितने भी
नोट्स हैं, रिसोर्सेज हैं या व्हाटएवर इज़
बीइंग शेयर्ड ओनली इन दिस ग्रुप और कहीं
आपको नहीं मिलने वाली है। और जो भी
अपकमिंग हमारी अपडेट्स होंगी इस सीरीज के
रिगार्डिंग या हम अगर इसके रिगार्डिंग कोई
सर्टिफिकेशन आपको या कोई इंटरव्यू से
रिलेटेड कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन या जॉब से रिलेटेड
इनफेशन देंगे वो इसी ग्रुप में देंगे। तो
इसको जॉइ कर लीजिएगा। ठीक है? हां। अभी
इनके बाद क्या है? Lindin Lindin पे आप
आके मुझे फॉलो कर सकते हैं। मुझसे कनेक्ट
कर सकते हैं। मुझसे इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हैं।
यह आईडी है। यहां पे आप देख रहे होंगे ऊपर
में यहां पे यूआरएल में भी आपको मिल जाएगी
आईडी। हैंडल मिल जाएगा बेसिकली। एंड यहीं
पे Lindin पे अगर आप डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च कर
लेते हैं तो आपको हमारा डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का Lindin पेज मिल जाता है।
बेसिकली यह Lindin पेज हमारी कंपनी का पेज
है। इसको जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। क्योंकि
कंपनी के साइट से जो भी कोई नई अपडेट्स
अनाउंसमेंट्स होती है, कोई गिव अवे होता
है, किसी तरह का हम फ्री कोर्स ऑफर ल्च
करते हैं, व्हाटएवर तो आपको इसी पर्टिकुलर
पेज पे ही मिलेगी वो जानकारी। तो इसको
जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। लास्ट गिव अवे का
भी रिजल्ट वगैरह यहां पे पब्लिश हुआ था।
उसके बाद हमारी Instagram पे डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी हैंडल है जो कि हमारी डिफ्रॉनिक्स
का Instagram पेज है। इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल
रील्स के लिए कंटेंट्स के लिए आप इसको
फॉलो कर सकते हैं। जैसे आप देख सकते हैं
रिसेंटली हमने यहां पे कंटेंट काफी
अच्छे-अच्छे डाले हैं कि कैसे एसओसीएल वन
क्रैक करना है? हिडन वलेबिलिटीज़ कैसे
फाइंड करनी है? साइबर किल चेन क्या होता
है? क्या इनकॉग्निटो मोड सेफ है? ये सारी
चीजें इसको फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। देन हमारे
एक्स का बार एक्स का है। एक्स की पेज आती
है जो कि एक्स पेज है। Twitter पेज। तो
बेसिकली यह डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल है।
यहां आकर आप हमें फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। यहां
भी आपको फदर डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ अपडेट्स एंड
पोस्ट्स मिलेगी। उसके बाद यह मेरा खुद का
पर्सनल Instagram पेज है। यू कैन कम हियर।
यू कैन फॉलो मी। यू कैन कनेक्ट वि मी। यू
कैन सी द लाइफ स्टाइल एंड व्हाटएवर ऑन
डेली लाइफ में क्या जा रही है, क्या हो
रहा है, वो सब कुछ आप देख सकते हो। मैं
वैसे तो ज्यादा अपडेट नहीं करता बट स्टिल
जितना करता हूं। यू कैन कनेक्ट वि मी। यह
हमारी [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
वेबसाइट है। रिवैंप हो रही है। अभी
बिल्कुल न्यू लुक आपको दिखने वाली है कुछ
ही टाइम के बाद। तो इसको जरूर बुकमार्क
करके रखिएगा। यहां से बुकमार्क का ऑप्शन
होता है। एंड विजिट करते रहिएगा। यहां
आपको सारी अपडेट्स एंड सारी जानकारी हमारे
बारे में हमारी कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग हमारे
कोर्सेज सब कुछ मिल जाएगी। यह हमारा
WhatsApp नंबर होता है। बेसिकली यहां पे
आप हमसे कोई भी तरह का क्वेरी हो, सवाल
हो, क्वेश्चन हो इस पे आप मैसेज करके हमसे
पूछ सकते हैं। हमसे कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं।
ठीक है? साथ ही में एकडमी पे जाके हमारे
जितने भी कोर्सेज हैं उनको एक्सप्लोर कर
सकते हैं। ठीक है? चलिए ये सारी चीजें हो
गई। नाउ लेट्स गेट बैक टू द टॉपिक।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके? चलिए आज का टॉपिक जो है वो मैंने
पहले ही बोला कि हम स्प्लक के बारे में
जानने वाले हैं। ठीक है? अपने आप में बहुत
ही एक इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है। स्प्लंक काफी
ज्यादा वाइडली यूज्ड एक एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन
है। ठीक है? अब यहां पे स्प्लंक मैंने
क्यों चूज़ किया है? क्योंकि यह एक सबसे
ज्यादा यूज़ होने वाला एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन है।
वैसे तो बहुत सारे और भी है। ठीक है? आप
सेंटेनल है। आप जैसे वाजू मैंने बताया।
देयर आर लॉट ऑफ़ टूल्स देयर आर लॉट ऑफ़
टूल्स जो प्रेजेंट है। बट इस प्लग को सबसे
ज्यादा यूज़ किया जाता है। काफी इजी इनका
यूआई है। इंटरफ़ेस काफी अच्छा होता है।
काफी ज्यादा फंक्शनैलिटीज़ प्रोवाइड करते
हैं। ए इंटीग्रेटेड प्लेटफार्म है। तो
देयर आर लॉट ऑफ़ पॉसिबिलिटीज़ यूजिंग
Splunk। तो आप जब कंपनी में जॉब के लिए
जाएंगे तो मोस्टली कंपनीज आपको स्प्लंक
यूज करने के लिए बोलेगी। स्प्लंक ऑफर
करेगी। कुछ-कुछ केसेस में वाजू या सेंटिनल
भी हो सकता है। ठीक है? तो हम यहां पे एक
कोई की क्योंकि हम एक ही प्लेटफार्म को
चूज़ करके चल सकते हैं। तो वी आर चूजिंग
स्प्लंक फॉर इट फॉर नाउ। राइट? सो मुझे
सभी लोग बताइए एवरीवन मैं यहां पे चैट भी
ओपन कर लेता हूं। एवरीवन एक्साइटेड फॉर
दिस डेमोंस्ट्रेशन सेशन क्योंकि आज का
सेशन थोड़ा सा कम थ्योरी डेमोंस्ट्रेशन
ज्यादा होने वाला है तो आपको बहुत ज्यादा
मजा आने वाला है। हम बिल्कुल स्टार्टिंग
से स्टार्ट करेंगे और मैं आपको पूरी चीज
मतलब इस क्लास के बाद आपको स्प्लक का सब
कुछ समझ में आ जाएगा। कोर आपको स्प्ल के
बारे में पता चल जाएगी। किस तरीके से
चीजें इस प्लंक के अंदर काम करती है वह
पता चल जाएगा। किसी कंपनी में आप जाएंगे
तो आप इस प्लंक को यूज़ कर पाएंगे। हां अब
इस प्लंक के अंदर थाउजेंड्स ऑफ थिंग्स आर
देयर। तो वो उसको मैंने पूरा एक समराइज
करके ना एक अच्छे तरीके से स्ट्रक्चर वे
में आपको डिलीवर करने की आज कोशिश करूंगा
मैं। ठीक है? आई होप कि यू अंडरस्टैंड
राइट?
चलिए। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सो
यहां पे अब हम करते हैं। वी विल बी
स्टार्टिंग हियर। नाउ अ
लेट्स बिगिन। एवरीवन एक्साइटेड गाइस?
एवरीवन एक्साइटेड?
यस।
चलिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। गुड गुड गुड गुड गुड गुड चलिए ओके
चलिए लेट्स स्टार्ट राइट लेट्स स्टार्ट
सबसे पहले तो मैं इस प्लन के बारे में
थोड़ा सा आईडिया दे देता हूं सर आई हैव
स्टार्टेड दिस सीरीज लेट बट
आई हैव कंप्लीटेड एवरीथिंग ग्रेट ग्रेट
ग्रेट यशराज प्लीज स्पैम मत कीजिए अ एक ही
मैसेज को बार-बार मत कीजिए वी हैव टू
जस्ट म्यूट यू सो प्लीज डोंट डू
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
स्प्लक इज अ
हॉरिजॉन्टल सॉफ्टवेयर प्लेटफार्म डिज़ फॉर
सर्चिंग, मॉनिटरिंग एंड एनालाइजिंग मशीन
जनरेटेड बिग डेटा इन रियल टाइम। मशीन
जनरेटेड डेटा को बेसिकली यह एनालाइज करने
के लिए टूल यूज़ में लिया जाता है। सिंपल
सा यह टूल का मतलब समझ लीजिए। स्प्लंक।
ठीक है? इट कैप्चर्स इंडेक्सेस एंड
कोरिलेट्स डेटा इन अ सर्चेबल रेपोज़िटरी।
यह क्या करता है? इसके पास जो डाटा आती
है, इसके पास जो डाटा बेसिकली
होती है, उसको यह इंडेक्स भी करता है,
कोरिलेट करता है, नॉर्मलाइज करता है। एंड
एक सर्चेबल फॉर्मेट में आपके सामने ला के
रख देता है। ठीक है? जहां से आप डेटा को
सर्च कर सकते हैं। मतलब यू कैन सर्च अ
लार्ज नंबर ऑफ़ डेटाज़ इनसाइड इट। एंड उस
डेटा के बेसिस पे आप ग्राफ्स क्रिएट कर
सकते हैं। चाहे वो पाई चार्ट के फॉर्म में
हो, बार चार्ट के फॉर्म में हो, किसी भी
तरह के चार्ट्स के फॉर्म में यू कैन
क्रिएट द ग्राफ्स। ठीक है? एंड जनरेट
ग्राफ्स, रिपोर्ट्स, अलर्ट्स, डैशबोर्ड्स
एंड विजुअलाइजेशंस। ठीक है? अलर्ट्स,
रिपोर्ट्स, डैशबोर्ड्स, विजुअलाइजेशन ये
सारी चीजें जो है आप कर सकते हैं। ठीक? इन
एन एंटरप्राइज नेटवर्क। इंटरप्राइज
नेटवर्क में स्प्लक इज द मास्टर
इंटेलिजेंस सिस्टम दैट लिस टू एव्री सिंगल
डिजिटल फुटप्रिंट।
एक इंटरप्राइज नेटवर्क के अंदर में स्प्लक
जो है एक मास्टर इंटेलिजेंस सिस्टम है जो
कि हर सिंगल डिजिटल फुटप्रिंट
के को मॉनिटर करता है फ्रॉम अ सर्वरर्स
लास्ट ब्रीथ टू अ रोग लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट।
मतलब कि सर्वर के ए टू जेड जितनी भी तरह
की डेटा या फुटप्रिंट होते हैं डिजिटल
फुटप्रिंट उनको क्या करता है? यह सुनता
रहता है। उनको क्या करता है? ये मॉनिटर
करता रहता है। तो दिस इज द स्प्लंक। यह
मॉनिटर करता रहता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सिंपल सिंपल
से वर्ड में अगर मैं बात करूं तो स्प्लंक
एक ऐसा टूल है, एक ऐसा प्लेटफार्म है, एक
ऐसा एसआईएम सॉल्यूशन है जो कि हर तरह के
डेटा को चाहे जितने भी तरह के डेटा मशीन
से आती है। चाहे आपका होस्ट से होस्ट से
वह डाटा निकलती है, कंप्यूटर से डाटा
निकलती हो या नेटवर्क से निकलती हो उन सब
डेटा को कलेक्ट करता है, कोरिलेट करता है,
नॉर्मलाइज करता है, इंडेक्स करता है। ये
सारी चीजें करके और उसको एक रेपोजिटरी एक
डायरेक्टरी बनाती है सर्चेबल डायरेक्टरी
जिसके अंदर आप सर्च करके कुछ भी इजी वे
में फाइंड कर सकते हैं। एंड यही इसका काम
होता है। तो जितने भी लॉग्स जनरली डेटा
कौन क्या होती है वो? वो डेटा होती है
लॉग्स। तो जितने भी लॉग्स आ रहे हैं जो भी
चीजें आ रही है वो सारी चीजें वो सारी जो
डेटा है उनको ये प्रोसेस करता है। यह
हमारा होता है स्प्लक। अब
एक्सीलेंट कोर्स इन ईजीली अंडरस्टैंडेबल
फॉर फ्रेशर्स। हेड्स ऑफ टू द नेट सर फॉर
प्रोवाइडिंग एक्सीलेंट क्वालिटी कंटेंट
फ्री ऑफ़ कॉस्ट। ग्रेट यशराज। अच्छी बात
है। अगर आपको अच्छा लग रहा है यह ट्रेनिंग
तो। एंड
चलिए अब यहां पे स्प्लक के आर्किटेक्चर को
भी हम समझेंगे। बट उसके पहले उसके पहले
मैं आपको स्प्ल का ओवरव्यू थोड़ा देना
चाहता हूं। सिंपल सा आपको क्या करना है?
Google पे स्प्ल सर्च करना है। स्प्लplunं
सर्च करेंगे तो आपको स्प्ल की वेबसाइट मिल
जाएगी। ठीक है? स्प्ल की वेबसाइट को आप
ओपन करेंगे। यू विल ओपन द स्प्लंक
वेबसाइट। कुछ इस तरीके से स्प्लंक की
वेबसाइट आपको देखने को मिल जाती है। सो
नाउ स्प्लंक के केस में यहां पे सबसे बड़ी
चीज क्या है कि ये फ्री ट्रायल आपको ऑफर
करता है फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट। ठीक है? मतलब कि
कोई भी आपको पैसा यहां पर नहीं देना पड़ता
है। 60 दिन का फ्री ट्रायल मिलता है। 60
डेज 2 मंथ्स का फ्री ट्रायल मिलता है। तो
आप लोग फ्री ट्रायल का यूज़ कर सकते हैं।
कोई क्रेडिट कार्ड की रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं
है। हां, आप आराम से इसको यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। अब यहां पे ट्रायल एंड डाउनलोड्स का
ऑप्शन है। इस पे आप जब जाएंगे तो यहां पे
आपको ऑप्शन मिल जाएगा। स्टार्ट फ्री
ट्रायल का इस तरीके का ऑप्शन मिल जाता है।
ठीक है? तो स्प्लंक क्लाउड प्लेटफार्म एक
आपको मिलेगा। एक स्प्लंक एंटरप्राइज जो है
यह आपको मिलेगा। ठीक है? तो आप यहां पे
डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं इस स्प्लक टूल को।
हालांकि मैंने जो है यहां पे ऑलरेडी यहां
पे आपको दिखा देता हूं। मैंने ऑलरेडी
डाउनलोड किया हुआ है। ये मैंने ऑलरेडी
यहां पे डाउनलोड किया हुआ है। आप इसमें से
जो भी आपको
डाउनलोड करना है वो आप डाउनलोड कर सकते
हैं। ठीक है? तो आप यहां पे या फिर आप
सिंपल वैसे डायरेक्ट अगर रीच आउट करना
चाहते हैं तो स्प्लंक
डाउनलोड आप ऐसे कर लीजिएगा फॉर Windows तो
आपको डायरेक्ट Windows का डाउनलोड लिंक भी
यहां पे Google से मिल जाएगा। ऐसा भी आप
कर सकते हैं। एंड यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
Splanger 10.4.2 का डाउनलोड। आप वहां से
पेज पे भी से भी जाके एंटरप्राइज पे कर
सकते हैं। यहां पे एक एक क्या है? आपको
क्या करना पड़ेगा? यहां पे आपको ये कुछ
डिटेल्स फिल करने हैं। पासवर्ड, फर्स्ट
नेम, बिज़नेस मेल, जॉब टाइटल ये सारी चीजें
आपको फिल करने हैं। और उसके बाद क्रिएट
अकाउंट करना है। देन आपका अकाउंट वेरीफाई
हो जाएगा। ईमेल पे वेरिफिकेशन मेल आएगी।
आप वेरीफाई कर लीजिएगा, लॉग इन कर
लीजिएगा। देन आपको डाउनलोड का ऑप्शन आ
जाएगा। यू कैन डाउनलोड। लगभग 1 GB की फाइल
है आपकी। एंड डाउनलोड जब कर लेंगे, तो कुछ
इस तरीके की जैसे यह फाइल डाउनलोड हुई है,
लगभग 1 GB की यह डाउनलोड हो जाएगी। एंड
इसको आप इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं। अब
इंस्टॉलेशन के हम प्रोसेस को
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हम
इंस्टॉलेशन की प्रोसेस को जो है स्टार्ट
करते हैं। तो डाउनलोडेड फाइल पे डबल क्लिक
करना है आपको। इंस्टॉलेशन प्रोसेस स्टार्ट
होनी शुरू हो जाएगी। कुछ इस तरीके से।
यहां पे आपको चेक करना है एग्रीमेंट
एक्सेप्ट करने के लिए लाइसेंस एग्रीमेंट।
उसके बाद यहां पे आपको नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक
करना है। देन आपको एक यूजरनेम बनाना है।
तो मैं यहां पे यूजरनेम बना देता हूं।
स्प्लक
अ एडमिन इस नाम से स्प्लंक एडमिन पासवर्ड
यहां बना देता हूं। हम
चलिए यहां पे पासवर्ड बना देते हैं।
नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक करते हैं। पासवर्ड फेल्स
टू मीट मिनिमम कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी
रिक्वायरमेंट। ठीक है? पासवर्ड थोड़ा
कॉम्प्लेक्स चाहिए इनको।
चलिए हमने पासवर्ड थोड़ा कॉम्प्लेक्स किया।
देखते हैं अब हो गया। चलिए हो गया। अब
यहां पे इंस्टॉल का ऑप्शन आएगा। इंस्टॉल
पे क्लिक कर देना है एंड इट विल स्टार्ट
गेटिंग इंस्टॉल्ड। सो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जस्ट वेट एंड
लेट इट इंस्टॉल। सो आप सभी लोग इसको यूज़
कर सकते हैं। फ्री ट्रायल है। कोई क्रेडिट
कार्ड की रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। ऑफिशियल
वेबसाइट से डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं। 60 दिन
का ट्रायल होता है। आपको कौन सा अपने
सिस्टम पे यूज़ करना है। इसको बस ट्राई
करना है। देखना है कैसे काम करती है।
क्योंकि आपके पास उतनी बड़ी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
है नहीं कि आप इस प्लग को यूज़ करोगे,
चलाओगे। कोई मतलब नहीं बनता है। सो वी आर
इंस्टॉलिंग।
आई हैव ऑलरेडी डाउनलोडेड। ठीक है। बहुत
अच्छी बात है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
चलिए सबने लाइक ठोक दिया है ना लाइक ठोकते
हुए लाइक्स की संख्या बढ़ा दीजिए आप लोग
एंड शेयर तो करते हो आप लोग वीडियोस को आई
थिंक करते रहना शेयर लोगों के बीच यहां अह
स्प्लक इंस्टॉलेशन में थोड़ा सा टाइम
लगेगा बट इट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] विल
इट विल बी वर्थ वेटिंग। सो वी विल वेट फॉर
इट टू कंप्लीट। ठीक है?
अब
अब ये जो इंस्टॉलेशन हो रही है,
इंस्टॉलेशन इसको बैकग्राउंड में हम होने
देते हैं। राइट?
यहां पे अब इंस्टॉलेशन जब तक हो रही है,
तब तक हम वापस से हमारे प्रेजेंटेशन पे
आते हैं और इसके कुछ कॉम्पोनेंट को समझते
हैं। ठीक है? देखो स्प्लक जो है यह इसका
आर्किटेक्चर
तीन कैटेगरी में डिवाइडेड मैंने किया है
आपके लिए। ठीक है? यह थ्री टियर पाइपलाइन
को फॉलो करता है। स्प्लंक इसी तरीके से
काम करता है। मतलब अगर आपसे कोई पूछे कि
स्प्लंक काम कैसे करता है? हाउ स्प्लंक
एक्चुअली वर्क्स? तो आपको बताना है
स्प्लंक वर्क्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यूजिंग थ्री टियर पाइप लाइन। थ्री टियर
पाइपलाइन की तरह काम करता है। ठीक है?
क्या है यह थ्री टियर्स में? देखो,
स्प्लंक्स पावर लाइट्स डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड
आर्किटेक्चर। ठीक है? आर्किटेक्चर में सब
कुछ है। इट ब्रेक्स डाउन द प्रोसेस ऑफ़
हैंडलिंग मैसिव डेटा सेट्स इनू थ्री
डिस्टिंक्ट लेयर्स। बहुत बड़ी डेटा सेट्स
को ये मैनेज करता है। ठीक है? उसको मैनेज
करने के लिए ये तीन लेयर्स में खुद को
डिवाइड करता है। तीन तरह के प्रोसेससेस
में ये डिवाइड करता है। एक होता है
फॉरवर्ड। दूसरा
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] होता है
इंडेक्सर्स, तीसरा होता है सर्च हेड्स।
तीन तरह के होते हैं। तो सबसे पहले होते
हैं फॉरवर्ड। उसके बाद होते हैं
इंडेक्सर्स एंड देन होता है सर्च हेड्स।
अब इन तीनों को हम एक-एक करके समझेंगे। वी
विल अंडरस्टैंड द थ्री ऑफ़ दीज़ कि
एग्जैक्टली क्या होता है ये। यहां पे देख
लेते हैं इंस्टॉलेशन प्रोसेस कितना हुआ
है। अभी-अभी चल रहा है क्योंकि थोड़ी बड़ी
सॉफ्टवेयर है। बड़ा काम करती है। तो थोड़ा
टाइम आपको लगेगा टू गेट इट इंस्टॉल। ठीक
है? अब यहां पे तीन चीजों को मैं बहुत ही
बेसिक तरीके से पहले समझा देता हूं। उसके
बाद हम डिटेल में थोड़ा सा जाएंगे। पहले
बेसिक तरीके से समझाता हूं। ठीक है? देखो
फॉरवर्डर का काम होता है डेटा को कलेक्ट
करना। अभी यही समझो। अभी ये नीचे की चीजें
ना इसको छोड़ते
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हैं अभी
फिलहाल के लिए। फॉरवर्डर का काम होता है
डेटा को कलेक्ट करना। ठीक है? यह वही
एजेंट्स होते हैं। लाइट वेट एजेंट्स बोलते
हैं जो एंड पॉइंट्स पे यानी कि आपके
लैपटॉप पे, सर्वर्स पे, नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस
पे इंस्टॉल्ड होते हैं, लगे रहते हैं।
बहुत ही कम रिसोर्सेज का यूज़ करते हैं। और
वहां लगे वहां जब ये लगे रहते हैं, इनका
काम क्या है? इनका काम है डेटा को कलेक्ट
करना। जितने भी लॉग्स हैं, जितनी भी लॉग्स
जनरेट हो रही है, चाहे वो वेब सर्वर की
लॉग्स हो, Windows की लॉक्स हो, फायरवॉल
की लॉग्स हो, वीपीए की लॉग्स हो, जितने भी
सिक्योरिटी लॉग्स हो, सारे लॉग्स को
कलेक्ट करना इनका काम है। तो ये है
कलेक्टर भैया। उसके बाद आते हैं ठीक है?
द इंडेक्सर्स।
अब आते हैं हमारे इंडेक्सर्स पे। अभी
फिलहाल अगेन इस पे नहीं जाते हैं।
इंडेक्सर्स का काम है डेटा को पास करना और
डेटा को स्टोर करना। मतलब यह क्या है?
गाड़ी जैसे गाड़ी का इंजन मान लो गाड़ी का
एक इंजन है। तो ये क्या करते हैं? जो भी
डाटा कलेक्ट हुई रहती है उसको यह रिसीव
करता है और उन सारे डेटा को एक
स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में डिवाइड कर देता है।
एक स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में डिवाइड करता है।
जिसको कि हम बेसिकली बोलते हैं कि एक
वैल्यू होती है और एक वेरिएबल। मतलब एक
कोई वेरिएबल है, एक उसकी वैल्यू है, उसमें
वह डिवाइड कर देता है। ठीक है? तो, दो
कॉलम्स में एक तरह का उसको डिवाइड सारे
डेटा को डिवाइड कर देता है और उन डेटा को
उनके मेटा डेटा से टैग कर देता है। सिंपल।
अब इसको भी डिटेल में समझेंगे। बट अभी
फिलहाल के लिए बस इतना ही कि ये क्या करता
है? डेटा को पास करता है। डेटा को स्टोर
करके रखता है और डेटा को एक स्ट्रक्चरर्ड
वे में ब्रेकडाउन करता है। तोड़ के रखता
है और आपके आपके लिए रखता है। तीसरा जो
होता है वो है द सर्च हेड्स। यह हमारे
सर्च हेड्स वही है जो डेटा को आप बेसिकली
सर्च कर सकते हो। आपका जो सर्चिंग का
इंटरफेस होता है
वही सर्च हेड्स है। मतलब कि जो भी लॉग्स
आपके इस प्लंक में आई है
तो आप जब कोई चीज उसमें सर्च करते हो तो
वह इसी के थ्रू होता है। आपको जो रिजल्ट्स
आते हैं वो इसी के थ्रू आपको प्रोवाइड
किया जाता है। तो यह होते हैं सर्च हेड्स।
तो पहला है आपका फॉरवर्डर डेटा को कलेक्ट
करने वाला। दूसरा डेटा को अरेंज करने
वाला, स्ट्रक्चर वे में करके आपके सामने
नॉर्मलाइज करके पास करके देने वाला। तीसरा
है डेटा को जब आप सर्च करो सर्च कर पाओ और
सर्च करके आपको सामने दिखाने वाला ये तीन
स्टेप्स में स्प्लक काम करता है। दैट्स इट
काम खत्म। बस इतना ही। अभी के लिए इतना ही
समझते हैं। ठीक है? इसको हम और डीप थोड़ा
सा टेक्निकली भी समझेंगे। बट थोड़ी देर
बाद। अब हम वापस से इंस्टॉलेशन पे वापस से
आते हैं। एंड यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कि स्प्लक
एंटरप्राइज इंस्टॉल हो चुका है। एंड यहां
आ रहा है लॉन्च ब्राउज़र वि स्प्लंक
एंटरप्राइes। तो ठीक है हम यहां पे फिनिश
पे क्लिक करते हैं। जैसे ही फिनिश पे
क्लिक करेंगे ब्राउज़र भी एक ल्च होगी
Splunk के साथ के लिए। एंड यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं कि Microsoft एज में यहां पे
हमारा क्योंकि बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट ये ब्राउज़र सेट
है फॉर फॉर ओपनिंग दीज़ काइंड ऑफ़ लिंक्स।
तो यहां पे हमारा स्प्लंक का एक लोकल
होस्ट कॉलन 8000 पोर्ट पे ये ओपन हो चुका
है। हां अब बात ये है कि क्या यहीं से
डायरेक्ट ओपन होता? अगर आप दूसरे ब्राउज़र
में भी ओपन करना चाहते हैं। जैसे मैं
Chrome में ही यहां पे ओपन करना चाहता
हूं। तो आई कैन डू इट। मैं यहां पे लोकल
होस्ट करके
लोकल होस्ट कॉलन 8000 पोर्ट पे मैं यहां
पे भी उसको ओपन कर सकता हूं। यहां पे भी
ये ओपन हो जाएगी। अगर आप लोकल होस्ट से
नहीं करना चाहते हैं तो आप अपने होस्ट नेम
से भी कर सकते हैं। जैसे आपके सिस्टम का
होस्ट नेम जैसे होता है ना सीएमडी तो
मैंने सीएमडी ओपन किया। ठीक है? अब यहां
पे मैंने किया होस्ट नेम एंटर किया। अब
मेरा होस्ट नेम डिफ्रॉनिक्स पीसी करके आ
रहा है। राइट? तो मैं इसको कॉपी कर लेता
हूं। और मैं इस लोकल होस्ट के जगह पे ना
सिर्फ डिफ्रॉनिक्स पीसी भी डाल दूं। तो ये
ओपन हो जाना चाहिए। सो लेट्स सी अ इफ इट
इज़ ओपनिंग। हां, यह फिर भी ओपन आपका
डिफ्रॉनिक्स पीसी वाला से भी हो रहा है।
इवन आप अपनी IPपी एड्रेस से जो IP कॉन्फ़िग
में आपको IPपी एड्रेस यहां मिल रही है
करंट IPपी एड्रेस जो लोकल IPपी एड्रेस मिल
रही है उस IPपी एड्रेस को भी यहां पे ओपन
करेंगे।
लाइक ये IPपी एड्रेस हो गई। कॉलन 8000
पोर्ट पे [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो
भी यह आपका ओपन हो जाएगा। सो कैसे भी करके
आप इसको ओपन कर सकते हैं। नो डाउट। अब फिर
से लोकल होस्ट पे भी आप इसको जैसे करना है
कर सकते हैं। तो मैं Chrome पे ही करता
हूं। एज को मैं फिलहाल क्लोज कर देता हूं।
Chrome पे ही इसको हम एक्सेस करने की
कोशिश करेंगे। अब यहां पे यूजरनेम मांग
रहा है। तो यूजरनेम वही यूजरनेम होगा जो
हमने यूजरनेम दिया था। तो मैंने दिया था
स्प्लंक
अ स्प्लंक एडमिन और पासवर्ड मैंने जो दिया
था वो पासवर्ड डाल देते हैं। ठीक है? और
यहां पे साइन इन पे क्लिक करूंगा। मैं
साइन इन पे जैसे ही क्लिक करूंगा यह लॉगिन
हो जाएगा।
सो जस्ट वेट इट्स लोडिंग
एंड [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वी आर गोइंग
टू सी द एक्चुअल
स्प्लंक
डैशबोर्ड। सो आप यहां पे एक रियल स्प्लंक
डैशबोर्ड देख रहे हैं जो आपको यहां पे
देखने को मिल रहा है। तो यह जो है यह है
आपका स्प्लंक डैशबोर्ड। अब यह जो स्प्लंक
डैशबोर्ड है गाइस, दिस इज़ द रियल डैशबोर्ड
जो आप बेसिकली आपको देखने को मिलेगा। जब
आप किसी कंपनी में भी जब जाएंगे वहां जब
काम करेंगे तो यह ऐसा ही आपको देखने को
मिलता है। यहीं से आपको चीजें मैनेज करनी
है। सब कुछ यहीं से आप एसओसी एनालिस्ट
हैं। एक एसओसीएल वन है तो आपके लिए यही गो
टू टूल है। आपका डेली टूल है। डेली यूज़
टूल है जिसको कि
सारी चीजें आप जो है वो यूज करने वाले
हैं। सर [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] मैं
आपको 2022 में देखा था बग हंटिंग लाइव
क्लास में और आज अभी देख रहा हूं। अब पहले
से मोटे हो गए हो। क्या बात है। धन्यवाद।
धन्यवाद। थैंक यू वेरी मच।
धन्यवाद भाई साहब। चलिए।
ओके। ये तो आपको समझ में आ गया। अब देखिए।
जस्ट अ सेकंड।
हां जी। अब ठीक है। मेरे को दिख रहा है अब
चैट में। हां। तो ये इंस्टॉलेशन इसकी हो
गई। हमने इसको ओपन कर लिया है। तो अभी
इसके कॉम्पोनेंट्स को हम इसकी चीजों को
समझेंगे बट ऐसे डायरेक्ट नहीं समझेंगे
क्योंकि ऐसे आपको समझ में नहीं आने वाला
है। तो हम इसको एग्जांपल के थ्रू एंड
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन के थ्रू समझेंगे। लैब्स के
थ्रू भी समझेंगे। सारी चीजें करेंगे। बट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] उसके पहले
मैं कुछ और चीजें आपको दिखाना चाहता हूं।
सो यहां पे हमने ये तीन चीजें देखी थी।
डेटा कलेक्शन, फॉरव ऑर्डर्स, डेटा
पार्सिंग एंड स्टोरेज करता है इंडेक्सेस
और डेटा एनालिटिक्स एंड विजुअलाइजेशन करता
है सर्च एट्स। ठीक है? ये तीन चीजें
एग्जैक्टली होती है जैसे प्लंक आपका काम
करता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? अब यहां पे मैं आपको डिटेल थोड़ा
लेकर जाना चाहता हूं इस चीज के अंदर। तो,
डेटा कलेक्शन फॉरवर्डर की जब बात करते
हैं, तो ये किस तरीके से होता है?
फॉरवर्ड्स आर लाइट वेट एजेंट्स इंस्टॉल्ड
डायरेक्टली ऑन योर एंड पॉइंट्स। एंड पॉइंट
का मतलब है जो लैपटॉप है, सिस्टम है,
सर्वर है उसके ऊपर क्लाउड कंटेनर्स जो
क्लाउड कंटेनर्स होते हैं या एप्लीकेशन
सर्वर्स पे ये इंस्टॉल्ड होते हैं। देयर
सोल पर्पस इज़ टू कंज्यूम अ रॉ फाइल
स्ट्रीम एंड शिप इट आउट सिक्योरली। इनका
काम होता है कि रॉ फाइल को यह क्या करें?
इनपुट की तरह ले और इसके बाद इसको पूरी
तरीके से आगे शिफ्ट करें। इनका यह काम
होता है कलेक्शन का, कलेक्ट करने का। तो
स्प्लंक जैसी टूल जो होती है उनमें किसी
भी तरह का डेटा एनी टाइप ऑफ डेटा कैन बी
टेकन एज इनपुट। ये ऑलमोस्ट हर तरह के
फॉर्मेट को सपोर्ट करते हैं। मतलब हर तरह
के डेटा को सपोर्ट करते हैं। आप किसी भी
तरह का डेटा इसमें डालिए और ये आपको मस्त
शानदार तरीके से क्या करेगा? आपको इंडेक्स
वगैरह करके सब कुछ करके और आपको फाइनल
सर्च वाले एक डेटाबेस के अंदर में भर के
यहां पे दे देगा। सर्चेबल एक डेटाबेस बना
के दे देगा। ठीक है? एग्जांपल
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] अ
यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्ड सीट्स ऑन अ Windows
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी कंट्रोलर हुक्स इंटू द
Windows इवेंट चैनल कंप्रेसेस द
सिक्योरिटी इवेंट लॉक्स एंड पाइप्स देम
ओवर टीसीp पोर्ट इतना टू द नेक्स्ट टियर।
मतलब ये एग्जांपल के तौर पर मैंने यहां पे
लिखा है कि एक यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर जो आपने
पिछले क्लासेस में मैंने बताया हुआ था
यूनिवर्सल फॉरवर्डर के बारे में। तो वो
उसी फॉरवर्डर की बात कर रहे हैं कि वो भी
अलग-अलग तरह के फॉरवर्डर होते हैं। पिछले
क्लासेस में मैंने बताया था। आप उसको जो
एसआईएम वाली क्लास हुई थी उसको जरूर देख
लीजिएगा अगर आपने नहीं देखा होगा तो।
हालांकि छोटा सा पार्ट मैंने बताया था
यहां पे। तो ये क्या करता है? उसी तरीके
से कि Windows एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी कंट्रोलर
पे रहता है। उसके बाद इवेंट्स चैनल्स के
अंदर में इंटीग्रेटेड रहता है और फिर क्या
करता है? वो अलग-अलग डेटा को वहां से
कलेक्ट करता है। उसी मशीन पे बैठा हुआ है
एंड उस वहां से डेटा कलेक्ट करने का काम
करता है। अब यहां पे इंडेक्सर जो है वो
कैसे काम करती है? उसके बारे में भी जान
जाते हैं। द इंडेक्सर इज़ द इंजन रूम। ठीक
है? इट रिसीव्स द रॉ डेटा स्ट्रीम्स। इसी
के पास रॉ डेटा जो है वो आती है।
स्प्लिट्स देम इंटू डिस्क्रीट इवेंट्स।
उनको इवेंट्स में डिस्क्रीट इवेंट्स में
वो स्प्लिट अप कर देती है। एक्सट्रैक्ट द
टाइम स्टैंप्स। टाइम स्टैंप्स को
एक्सट्रैक्ट करती है। जो भी टाइम स्टैंप्स
होते हैं उसके टैक्स देम विद मेटा और मेटा
डेटा मतलब उनकी जो उनकी जो विशेषताएं जो
बेसिकली एडजेक्टिव्स होती हैं लाइक कहां
से आया है? या डेटा कहां से आया है? सोर्स
क्या है? उसका होस्ट कौन सा है? ठीक है?
तो वो सारी चीजें उसके साथ जोड़ देती है।
मतलब मेटा डेटा मतलब उससे रिलेटेड फर्दर
इंफॉर्मेशन उसके साथ कनेक्ट कर देती है।
एंड सेव्स देम टू अ टाइम सीरीज डेटाबेस।
और टाइम सीरीज डेटाबेस की तरह उसको सेव कर
दिया। एक टाइम वाली सीरीज में। अभी हम एक
एग्जांपल डेटा जो है वो अपलोड करेंगे
हमारे स्प्लंक में और उसके बाद हम उसको
देखेंगे, एनालाइज़ करेंगे एग्जैक्टली कि
कैसा वो आपको दिखता है। ठीक है? आपको और
भी ज्यादा क्लियर होगा जब हम टूल के ऊपर
देखेंगे यह सारी चीजें। अभी तो हम आपको
अभी हम थ्योरिटिकली समझ रहे हैं। इसको हम
टूल पे वापस से देखने वाले हैं। एंड एक
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन भी होगा आपका तो आपको फिर
उस टाइम में मजा आएगा। ठीक है? अब यहां पे
द स्टोरेज लाइफ से स्प्लंक ऑर्गेनाइजेस
डेटा इनू फिजिकल डायरेक्टरीज़ ऑन डिस्क्
कॉल्ड बकेट्स। अब स्प्लक क्या करता है ना?
फिजिकल डायरेक्टरीज़ जो होती हैं डिस्कक्स
पे मतलब स्टोर जैसे आपके लैपटॉप में क्या
होता है? एसएसडी हार्ड डिस्क होता है ना
वैसे ही स्टोरेज डिवाइसेस होती हैं। उसमें
वो डेटा को ऑर्गेनाइज करके रखता है। उनको
हम बकेट्स बोलते हैं। और इन बकेट्स को
बेसिकली चार टाइप के यहां पे स्टोरेज
बकेट्स में डिवाइड किया गया है। स्टोरेज
करने का चार यहां पे चार तरीका होता है
स्टोरेज करने का। एक हॉट बकेट, एक वार्म
बकेट, एक कोल्ड बकेट, एक फ्रोजन बकेट।
इनके बारे में आप में से कितने लोगों को
पता है? क्या मैंने इसके बारे में आप
लोगों को पहले बताया है? इनके बारे में
हॉट बकेट, वार्म बकेट, कोल्ड बकेट्स,
फ्रोजन बकेट्स के बारे में क्या मैंने आप
लोगों को पहले बताया है? मुझे बताइए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
लेट मी नो।
आई एम वेटिंग फॉर द रिस्पांस गाइस।
बताइए सभी लोग बताइए।
नहीं मालूम। देखिए जिन लोगों ने सही से
क्लासेस करी है उनको पता होगा लास्ट क्लास
में ही मैंने ये चीज बताई थी। अ बट अगर
आपका आप यूं ही क्लासेस करते हैं कोई मतलब
नहीं है। मतलब ऐसे ही कि हां चलो भाई देख
लेते हैं। ऊपर ऊपर से कहीं भी कुछ भी तो
फिर आपको कभी नहीं पता चलेगा कि ये मैंने
बताया था कि नहीं बताया था। ठीक है?
प्रीवियस क्लास में ही मैंने इनके बारे
में आपको बताया था। अच्छे से बताया था।
पूरी डिटेल में बताया था। इसलिए मैं इस
क्लास में इसको डिटेल में बात नहीं करने
वाला हूं। प्रीवियस क्लास जो है देख
लीजिएगा। इस क्लास के लिए प्रीवियस क्लास
जरूर देख लीजिएगा। अगर आप अभी भी हो तो
अभी आप कंटिन्यू कर सकते हैं। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। लेकिन प्रीवियस क्लास
भी आज की क्लास के बाद देख लीजिएगा। ठीक
है? तो ये चार तरह के बकेट्स होते हैं
यहां पे। बेसिकली यहां पे हॉट बकेट्स का
मतलब एक्टिव जो एक्टिवली उसमें डेटा राइट
हो रही है अभी करंट में जो डेटा स्टोर हो
रही है वो एक्टिव वो हॉट बकेट्स होते हैं।
वार्म बकेट्स होते हैं जो हॉट बकेट से ही
अ रोटेड होते हैं। मतलब कि अब उनमें डेटा
तो राइट नहीं हो रही है। स्टोर हो चुकी है
डेटा बट अब उसमें स्टोर नहीं हो रही है।
अब उसमें फर्दर स्टोरेज नहीं हो रही है।
उससे अब सर्चेस वगैरह ये सब सारी जगह काम
ये चीजें हो रही है। कोल्ड बकेट्स में जो
ओल्डर डेटा होती है। मतलब कि बेसिकली डाटा
को बहुत पहले से स्टोर करके रखा गया है।
एंड इसको बेसिकली चीप हार्ड डिस्कस जो
सस्ते हार्ड डिस्कक्स या स्टोरेज डिवाइसेस
होते हैं उनको यूज़ किया जाता है ओल्डर
डेटा को स्टोर करके रखने के लिए ताकि वो
हमेशा के लिए रहे। और देन फ्रोजन बकेट्स
होती है एक्सपायर्ड डेटा जो होती है उनको
रखने के लिए। ठीक है? जैसे कि अब मान लो
दो-ती साल पुराना डाटा हो गया या अगर
जरूरत नहीं है तो स्प्लंक क्या करता है कि
उनको डिलीट कर देता है या अनइंडेक्स्ड
करके उनको ऑफलाइन आर्काइव में डाल देता
है। अनइंडेक्स मतलब कि इंडेक्स होती है
तभी तो डाटा आपको रिट्रीव होती है। अब
जैसे ऑपरेटिंग आपके Windows के अंदर में
कोई डेटा आप कैसे रिट्रीव करते हो?
क्योंकि वो इंडेक्स होती है। किसी ना किसी
तरीके से किसी ना किसी एक पर्टिकुलर अ एक
चीज से जुड़ी होती है आपकी डेटा। जो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम उस डेटा को कॉल करती है
तो वो इंडेक्स डेटा होती है। और वही चीज़
जब डिलीट कर देते हो तो वो इंडक्शन आप
खत्म कर देते हो। तो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को
लगता है कि अरे यार ये तो डेट है ही नहीं
बल्कि डेटा तो होती है वहीं पे बट डेटा का
इंडक्शन नहीं होता है। इंडेक्स डेटा नहीं
होता है। तो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को मिलती
नहीं है। और जब मिलती नहीं है तो ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम को लगता है अच्छा डेटा नहीं है।
डिलीट हो रही है। उसी को हम डिलीटेड डेटा
बोलते हैं। दैट्स इट। तो ये था आपका
इंडेक्सर का काम। अब आता है डेटा
एनालिटिक्स एंड विजुअलाइजेशन वाला पार्ट
जो कि सर्च हेड्स का काम होता है। व्हाट
इट डज़? द सर्च हेड्स इज़ द यूजर इंटरफ़ेस।
ये आपका एक यूजर इंटरफ़ेस होता है। कौन सा
यूजर इंटरफ़ेस होता है? सर्च हेड्स। जैसे
कि मैंने स्प्लंक ये चालू किया है।
ये वाला स्प्लंक यूज़ किया है। अब ये सर्च
ये जो आप सर्चिंग एंड रिपोर्टिंग है सर्च
रिपोर्टिंग जब हम सर्च रिपोर्ट पे चलेंगे
यहां पे सर्च रिपोर्ट पे तो आपको यहां पे
देखने को मिलेगा। मैं यहां पे गॉट इट पे
क्लिक कर देता हूं।
नहीं क्विक टूर नहीं करना हमें। ये हटा
दीजिए। ये आपका सर्च वाला जो चीज है ये
सर्च वाला। यही आपका सर्च हेड्स होता है।
जहां पे आप कोई भी चीज जो है वो सर्च कर
सकते हैं। यू कैन सर्च इट। सर्च वाले पे
जाके। तो दिस इज़ कॉल्ड सर्च हेड्स। अब
यहां पे सर्च हेड्स भैया क्या है हमारे?
वह देखते हैं।
द सर्च हेड इज़ द यूजर इंटरफ़ेस। ये यूजर
इंटरफ़ेस है। इट हैंडल्स ज़ीरो लॉग स्टोरेज।
यह क्या करता है? ज़ीरो लॉग स्टोरेज यह
हैंडल करता है। व्हेन एन एनालिस्ट लॉग्स
इंटू स्प्लंक। ठीक है? एंड टाइप्स अ क्वरी
द सर्च हेड डिस्ट्रीब्यूट्स दैट वर्क लोड
अक्रॉस ऑल अवेलेबल इंडेक्सेस। अब जो
स्प्लंक्स जैसे टूल होते हैं एसआईएम टूल्स
होते हैं उनमें इंडेक्सर्स होते हैं।
इंडेक्सेस के थ्रू ही सारा काम होता है।
ठीक है? तो जब आप कोई चीज सर्च करते हो तो
स्प्लक जो है ना स्प्लंक का सर्च हेड जो
है उन सर्च क्वरीज को सारे इंडेक्सेस के
बीच डिवाइड कर देता है। एग्रीगेट्स द
रिजल्ट रिजल्ट्स को एग्रीगेट करता है एंड
डिस्प्लेस देम बैक टू द यूजर एज़ टेबल्स और
चार्ट्स। मतलब कि जैसे ही आपने कोई चीज़
सर्च की अब इस प्लंक का जो सर्च हेड है वो
क्या करता है? उन सर्च क्वरीज़ को
इंडेक्सर्स को। इंडेक्स का मतलब होता है
वो यूटिलिटी जो इंडेक्स करते हैं डेटा को।
को इंडेक्स करता है। इंडेक्स का मतलब होता
है एक दूसरे से लिंक कर देना। एक
स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में आपके सामने ला के रख
देना। तो डेटा को इंडेक्स करते हैं और
आपके सामने डिस्प्ले करते हैं टेबल्स या
चार्ट्स के फॉर्म में। ठीक है? तो ये जो
है आपके क्या है? दिस इज़ सर्च हेड। चलिए
अब इसके बाद एग्जैक्टली हाउ इट वर्क्स जो
पार्ट है ये भी पार्ट है। इसको भी मैं
यहां पे डील कर देता हूं। एग्जैक्टली काम
कैसे करता है? एंड तब हम जो है इसको
प्रैक्टिकली देखने वाले हैं। ठीक है? तब
हम इसको प्रैक्टिकली देखेंगे कि यह कैसे
एग्जैक्टली जो हमने थ्योरेटिकली पढ़ा, जो
हमने अभी सब चीजें पढ़ी वो कैसे जो है काम
करता है। ठीक है?
जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस।
हम हम
जस्ट अ सेकंड। ठीक है। हम ओके।
अब यहां पे है एग्जजेक्टली हाउ स्प्लंक
वर्क्स एंड यह वर्क करता है स्कीमा ऑन रीड
को फॉलो करके। ठीक है? स्कीमा ऑन रीड।
ठीक है? मतलब कि जीरो लॉग स्टोरेज का मतलब
होता है कि लॉग को बेसिकली
जब आप क्वेरी करते हो ना उसी टाइम वो आपको
सर्च करके ला के देता है। मैं इस चीज को
ना इस वाले पर्टिकुलर अभी स्लाइड में
ज्यादा क्लियर करूंगा कि एग्जैक्टली कैसे
काम करता है ना आपको वो ज़ीरो लॉग वाला
क्लियर हो जाएगा। देखिए ट्रेडिशनल रिलेशनल
डेटाबसेस जैसे जो ट्रेडिशनल डेटाबेस हैं
जैसे अभी मायसक्यूएल हो गया, एमएसएसक्यूएल
हो गया, एसक्यूएल सर्वर्स हो गए। ये
स्कीमा ऑन राइट स्कीम को फॉलो करते हैं।
स्कीमा ऑन राइट। ठीक है? इसका मतलब क्या
है? दिस मींस यू मस्ट डिफाइन योर टेबल्स,
रोज़, कॉलम्स एंड डेटा टाइप्स बिफोर यू कैन
सेव डेटा। इसका मतलब है कि डेटा को सेव
करने से पहले आपको
टेबल आपको अपना टेबल बनाना पड़ेगा, रोज़ को
डिफाइन करना पड़ेगा, कॉलम्स को डिफाइन
करना पड़ेगा, डाटा टाइप्स बताना पड़ेगा।
यह सब चीजें बतानी पड़ेंगी। यह तो आप
मायक्यूएल में देख ही रहे होंगे। अभी तक
आप सब में से जितने लोग मायesक्यूएल को
जानते होंगे या आप में से किसी ने अगर
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन वगैरह करा है तो उसमें
जो रिजल्ट्स आते हैं आप देखते होंगे कि
क्या होते हैं वहां पे। रोज़, कॉलम्स,
टेबल्स ये सारी चीजें होती है। राइट?
टेबल्स होती है, कॉलम्स होती है, डेटा
होता है। तो वहां पे एक इस फॉर्मेट में
आती है और वहां पे टेबल का नाम होता है,
डेटाबेस का नाम होता है, कॉलम का नाम होता
है। फिर उसके अंदर डेटा होती है। फिर डेटा
टाइप जैसे इंटीजर है, वेरिएबल है, क्या
है? वो सारी चीजें होती है। राइट? वो सारी
चीजें हम ट्रेडिशनल डेटाबेसिस जो रिलेशनल
डेटाबेस होते थे उनमें ये चीजें हम देखते
हैं। और वो सारे काम करते थे, कार करते
हैं अभी भी स्कीमा ऑन राइट पे। ठीक है? तो
आपको सब चीज बतानी पड़ती थी डेटा को सेव
करने से पहले डेटा को उसमें स्टोर करने से
भी पहले इफ अ लॉग फॉर्मेट चेंज
अनएक्सेक्टेडली द डेटाबेस रिजेक्ट्स इट।
अब इसमें क्या दिक्कत आती थी कि इसमें अगर
लॉग का फॉर्मेट कोई चेंज हो जाता था। जैसे
अगर फॉर्मेट है कि भैया एक टेबल का इस
तरीके से फॉर्मेट है। एक प्रीडफाइंड
फॉर्मेट है। उस फॉर्मेट को अगर चेंज किया
जाएगा तो पूरा का पूरा डेटाबेस ही क्रैश
कर सकता था। था। डेटाबेस जो है उसको क्या
होगा? रिजेक्ट कर देगा। डेटाबेस उसको
एक्सेप्ट नहीं करेगा और वो पूरी की पूरी
क्रैश कर जाएगी डेटाबेस। किसी भी तरह का
कोई भी अगर फॉर्मेट चेंज कर देते थे। अब
इस चीज को दूर कर देता है स्प्लंक।
स्प्लंक में ऐसा नहीं होता है। स्प्लंक
यूजज़ अ रिवोल्यूशनरी कांसेप्ट कॉल्ड
स्कीमा ऑन रीड। स्प्लंक में स्कीमा ऑन
राइट यूज़ नहीं होता। स्कीमा ऑन रीड यूज़
होता है। ठीक है? अब
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
क्या होता है इसमें? व्हेन लॉग अराइव जब
भी लॉग्स आते हैं स्प्लंक कीप्स देम इन
देयर
रॉ एंड नेटिव टेक्स्ट फॉर्मेट। जब भी
लॉग्स कोई आता है तो स्प्लंक क्या होता
है? उसको उसके रॉ और नेटिव टेक्स्ट
फॉर्मेट में रखता है। इट ओनली
एक्सट्रैक्ट्स अ फ्यू मैंडेटरी फील्ड्स ऑन
अराइवल। यह कुछ मैंडेटरी फील्ड्स को ही
एक्सट्रैक्ट करता है। जैसे कि टाइम स्टैंप
जो हो गया उसको एक्सट्रैक्ट करेगा। कौन सा
होस्ट किस होस्ट से ये लॉग आया है उसको
करेगा। सोर्स क्या था? मतलब कौन सी आईपी
सोर्स कहां से आया था या होस्ट होस्ट नेम
तो होस्ट से आ जाएगा। सोर्स कौन से आईपी
से आया था? और सोर्स टाइप तो वो किस तरह
के मशीन से आया था? किस तरह के टाइप्स
सर्वर थी, वर्क स्टेशन था या कोई डोमेन
कंट्रोलर था या कोई वीपीए तो वह क्या था?
तो वो सारी चीजें ये कुछ माइनर इनेशन
निकालता है पहले ही। ठीक है? सबसे पहले अब
द फील्ड्स इनसाइड द लॉग। जो लॉग के अंदर
फील्ड्स होते हैं, लाइक जैसे कि यूजर आईडी
हो गया, IPपी एड्रेस हो गया, एरर कोड्स हो
गई। आर नॉट कैलकुलेटेड अंटिल द एनालिस्ट
क्लिक सर्च। यह तब तक कैलकुलेट नहीं होते
हैं जब तक ये एसोसिए एनालिस्ट सर्च नहीं
करता है। अब आपको डिफरेंस समझ में आएगा।
स्प्लंक यूसेस द रेजिक्स कोड डायनेमिकली
एट द एग्जैक्ट सेकंड ऑफ सर्च एग्जीक्यूशन
टू आइसोलेट वेरिएबल्स। अब सर जो स्प्लंक
है वो रेजिक्स का इस्तेमाल यानी कि पर
डेटा सर्च का इस्तेमाल तब करता है जब
एक्चुअली यूजर सर्च करने जाता है। बाकी
डेटाबेस में क्या होता है? पहले से ही
डेटा को स्टोर कर लिया जाता है। डाटा को
स्टोर कर लिया जाता है। डेटा के अंदर सारी
जो भी स्टर्ड की डाटा है उसके अंदर सारी
इनेशन होती है। पहले से ही स्ट होता है।
उसमें आप सर्च करने जाते हैं। अब उस उस
पर्टिकुलर स्टर्ड डेटा की फॉर्मेट में अगर
किसी भी तरह का चेंज हो चेंज अगर कर दिया
जाएगा जो उसका डिफॉल्ट फॉर्मेट है। तो जब
आप सर्च करेंगे तो आपको सर्च रिजल्ट्स कुछ
मिलेगा ही नहीं। प्लंक में क्या होता है?
कोई भी पहले से प्रीडफाइंड स्टोरेज नहीं
होती है। ज़ीरो लॉग स्टोरेज। ठीक है? कोई
भी स्टोरेज पहले से नहीं होती है। जब आप
सर्च करने जाते हैं तो जो उसके पास इनपुट
डाटा होता है ना भरा एकदम पूरा भरा हुआ
इंडेक्स डेटा पूरा होता है उसी में से उसी
टाइम वो क्या करता है? वेरिएबल्स को उसके
वैल्यू के साथ निकालता है और आपको सर्व कर
देता है। आपको दे देता है। तो अगर कोई
चेंज भी आया किसी तरह के फॉर्मेट में तो
स्प्लंक को कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता है।
स्प्लक अपना आराम से डेटा निकालेगा और
आपको सर्च क्वरी के थ्रू आपको प्रोवाइड कर
देगा। बस यह अंतर है। व्हाई इट मैटर्स?
यही चीज मैं यहां पे लिखा है मैंने यहां
पे। इफ एन एप्लीकेशन डेवलपर मान लो आप
डेवलपर हो। डेवलप करते हो। अपडेट्स देयर
सॉफ्टवेयर कोड टुमारो। अब आपने अपना
सॉफ्टवेयर कोड कल को चेंज कर दिया। एंड
चेंजेस अ लॉग फील्ड और एक लॉग फील्ड थी जो
कि आप लिखते थे पहले यूजर अंडरस्कोर आईडी।
ये एक लॉग फील्ड थी जो पहले आप डेवलपमेंट
करते थे, कोड करते थे। तो आपने कोडिंग में
आप यूजर कॉलन आईडी इस तरीके का एक वेरिएबल
फील्ड बनाते थे जिसमें यूजर आईडी आप
यूज़र्स की मेंशन करते थे। अब उसको आपने
अकाउंट नंबर से चेंज कर दिया। अब आपने
यूजर आईडी हटा दिया। उसको कह दिया अकाउंट
अंडरस्कोर नंबर। अगर ये चेंज आपने
मायक्यूएल, एमएसएसक्यूएल जैसे रिलेशनल
डेटाबेस के केस में किया होगा या करेंगे
तो उसके बाद जब आप सर्च करेंगे उसके अंदर
क्वेरी करेंगे आप एसक्यूएल की क्वरी
चलाएंगे तो आपका क्वरी ब्रेक हो जाएगा।
डेटाबेस बोलेगी भैया ऐसा कोई डेटा मेरे
पास है ही नहीं जो आप खोज रहे हो। लेकिन
स्प्लक केस में ऐसा नहीं होगा। अ
स्टैंडर्ड डेटाबेस विल क्रैश और लूज़ डेटा।
स्टैंडर्ड डेटाबेस जो है क्रैश कर सकता
है। स्प्लक विल सिंपली स्वॉलो द टेक्स्ट
सेफली। स्प्लंक क्या करेगा कि भैया बोलेगा
अच्छा पहले यूजर आईडी था। अब अकाउंट नंबर
है आ जाओ कोई बात नहीं दिखा देंगे
तुम्हें। एंड द एनालिस्ट कैन एफर्टलेसली
एडजस्ट देयर सर्च लॉजिक ऑन द फ्लाई। और
एनालिस्ट अपनी सर्च लॉजिक को बस चेंज
करेगा कि वो क्या करेगा? यूजर आईडी के जगह
अकाउंट नंबर अब डालेगा, सर्च करेगा उसके
जगह पे एंड उसको वही डेटा मिलेगी जो यूजर
आईडी पे मिलने वाली थी। तो ये
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
फ्लैक्सिबिलिटी आ जाती है स्कीमा ऑन रीड
को यूज करने से देन सॉरी स्कीमा ऑन राइट
जो कि पहले यूज़ होती थी स्कीमा ऑन राइट अब
यूज़ होता है स्कीमा ऑन रीड अब आप लोगों का
ये डाउट जो था रिलेटेड टू ये तीन ये सारी
चीजें वो क्लियर हुआ आप लोगों को ये चीजें
समझ में आई या नहीं आई तो मुझे प्लीज
कमेंट्स में सभी लोग जितने भी अभी 60 लोग
प्रेजेंट हैं प्लीज प्लीज लेट मी नो
क्योंकि क्योंकि अब हम इसके डेमोंस्ट्रेशन
पार्ट पे चलेंगे। तो प्लीज बताइए इफ यू
अंडरस्टुड इट। मैं सभी की रिप्लाई की
एक्सपेक्ट एक्सपेक्टेशंस करता हूं कि सभी
लोग रिप्लाई करेंगे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
आ रही है समझ आपको बताइए
क्योंकि आज की पीपीटी बस छह स्लाइड की थी।
आज की पीपीटी खत्म क्योंकि आज प्रैक्टिकल
ओरिएंटेड है। मैंने बोला था डेमोंस्ट्रेशन
है थोड़ा तो आज की यहीं पे हमारी यह
पीपीटी तो खत्म हो जाती है लेकिन अभी
क्लास तो बची हुई है। अभी अभी मैं आपको
थोड़ा डेमोंस्ट्रेशन के ऊपर ले चलूंगा तब
आपको ज्यादा मजा आएगा।
अंडरस्टैंड
देखिए
ठीक है चलिए नहीं देखो समराइज तो कर दो
समराइज करने का कोई मतलब नहीं है देखो
क्या होता है रुद्र कि जो चीजें मैंने अभी
बताई है वही चीजें मैं वापस दोबारा
बोलूंगा तो उसमें टाइम जाएगा कोई मतलब
नहीं है इसके लिए आप दोबारा जब वीडियो
देखेंगे ना तो वो समराइज ही होगा। वो आपको
समझ में एग्जैक्ट आ जाएगी कि हां दोबारा
अगर कोई चीज आपको अगर अभी भी डाउट है तो
ठीक है तो एक बार प्लीज दोबारा देखिएगा।
ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] चलिए सो दिस वाज़
ऑल अबाउट द स्लाइड्स पार्ट। अब इस स्लाइड
पार्ट को हम बंद करते हैं। अब हम आ जाते
हैं हमारे स्प्लंक भैया के ऊपर। यहां पे
स्प्लक वाले भैया के पास आ जाते हैं। यह
रही। तो कुछ इस तरीके का यह प्लेटफार्म जो
है वह दिखता है। ठीक है?
हां रेजिक्स क्या है? आप रेजिक्स के बारे
में मैंने लास्ट क्लास में भी बताया था।
इसलिए मैं आपसे बोलता हूं कि प्लीज अटेंड
द क्लासेस या तो आप वीडियोस को पूरा देखा
कीजिए। ठीक है? चलिए यहां पे स्प्लंक का
एंटरप्राइज मेरे सामने आ चुका है यहां पे।
एंड कैन यू यूज़ टेम मेल? आई डोंट थिंक सो
कि टपल ही अलऊ करेंगे। बट एक बार देख लेना
करके।
यहां पे मैं स्प्लक के ट्राईकमी के एक रूम
पे हूं जो कि एक प्रीमियम रूम है स्प्लंक
बेसिक का। इस पे हम आ चुके हैं। यहां पे
इसको मैंने क्यों अभी स्टार्ट किया है?
इसके पीछे लॉजिक ये है कि यहां पे जो
चीजें मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा वो चीजें आपको
कहीं और देखने को नहीं मिल सकती है।
क्योंकि लाइव डेमोंस्ट्रेशन आपको एक
एनवायरमेंट के अंदर मिलेगी और वो
एनवायरमेंट यहां पे ऑलरेडी सेटअप है। हम
उसको यूज़ करेंगे। मतलब जो टूल हमने यहां
ल्च किया ना वही टूल हम यहां भी ल्च
करेंगे। तो एकदम बेफिक्र रहना है जो हमने
यहां पे टूल इस प्लंक को ल्च किया है। सेम
टूल वी आर गोइंग टू ल्च इट। राइट? तो यहां
पे इनका इंट्रोडक्शन पार्ट है। यहां पे
इंट्रोडक्शन पार्ट है। इसको हटाओ। कुछ
नहीं है। इंट्रोडक्शन पार्ट हटाओ। कनेक्ट
विद द लैब। अब यहां पे लैब से कनेक्ट करते
हैं। तो यहां पे दो चीजें हैं। एक अटैकर
की मशीन है अटैक बॉक्स जो है आपका और एक
है आपका लैब मशीन। ठीक है? तो दोनों चीजों
को स्टार्ट करनी है। तो हम स्टार्ट अटैक
बॉक्स। अटैकर की मशीन को स्टार्ट कर देते
हैं जो कि स्टार्ट हो जाएगी आपकी। यहां पे
स्टार्ट होनी आई थिंक शुरू हो गई है। एक
सेकंड। हां, यह स्टार्ट हो रही है। और एक
लैब मशीन है। लैब मशीन को भी हम स्टार्ट
कर देते हैं।
बोथ विल बी स्टार्टेड। राइट?
अब देखिए अब आएगा मजा।
इसमें हम एक लॉग जो है वो अपलोड करेंगे।
लॉग को यूज़ करेंगे। ये दोनों स्टार्ट हो
रहे हैं। यहां पे चेक कर देते हैं। इसमें
तो कुछ है नहीं वैसे।
ये स्टार्ट हो रहे उसके पहले मैं कुछ एक
गो थ्रू कर देता हूं। यहां पे इनको
स्टार्ट होने देते हैं। यहां पे इनका एक
और टास्क है स्प्लंक कंपोनेंट्स के बारे
में। तो ये वही चीजें हैं जो मैंने आपको
ऑलरेडी बता दी हैं। इंडेक्सर सर्च हेड
फॉरवर्ड्स जो स्प्लंक के पार्ट्स होते हैं
उन्हीं के बारे में इन्होंने ये बताया हुआ
है। आप इसको पढ़ लीजिएगा। हालांकि मैंने
इसको ऑलरेडी क्लियर कर दिया आपको। इससे
ज्यादा डिटेल में अच्छे तरीके से आपको बता
दिया है। वही चीज़ यहां पे दी हुई है कि
भैया स्पंक फॉरवर्डर जो है वो क्या करता
है? लाइट वेट एजेंट्स होते हैं। एंड
पॉइंट्स पे इंस्टॉल्ड होते हैं और जितने
भी ट्रैफिक्स लॉग्स हैं उनको कलेक्ट करते
हैं। इंडेक्सर उनको इंडेक्स करते हैं।
डेटा को प्रोसेस करते हैं जो फॉरवर्डर से
आए होते हैं। और सर्च हेड जो है जो आप
बेसिकली सर्च करते हो। दैट्स इट। यही चीज़
है। यहां पे क्या है? व्हिच कंपोनेंट इज़
यूज़्ड टू कलेक्ट एंड सेंड डेटा ओवर
स्प्लंक इंस्टेंसेस। तो इसको बोलते हैं
मॉनिटर करना। नहीं नहीं मॉनिटर नहीं ना।
व्हिच कंपोनेंट इज़ यूज़्ड टू कलेक्ट एंड
अच्छा फॉर ऑर्डर।
फॉरवर्डर फॉरव ऑर्डर ही होता है। फॉर
ऑर्डर हो गई। तो ये आपका नॉर्मल सा चीज ये
तो आपका नॉर्मल था। इसको मैं हटा देता हूं
यहां पे। अब आते हैं नेविगेटिंग स्प्लंक।
तो इसमें अब नेविगेटिंग स्प्लंक में हमारी
मेन चीज है यहां पे। व्हेन यू एक्सेस
स्प्लंक यू विल सी द डिफ़ॉल्ट होम स्क्रीन
एज शोन बिलो। कुछ इस तरीके से होम स्क्रीन
आप देखेंगे। तो यहां पे मैं बेसिकली यहां
जो स्टार्ट हुआ है, हम इसी में देखने वाले
हैं यहां पे। उसके बाद स्प्लंक बार एक आती
है। इसमें स्प्लंक बार में क्या होता है?
ऊपर के ऑप्शंस होते हैं जैसे मैसेजेस,
सेटिंग्स, एक्टिविटी ये सारी चीजें होती
हैं। इस प्लंक बार में एप्स पैनल में
लेफ्ट में एप्स पैनल होता है। ये सारी चीज़
तो इसको मैं वन टू वन ऐसे ना दिखाता भी
रहूंगा। तो मैं एक काम करता हूं। मैं इसको
यहां से क्लोज करके इसको न्यू टैब में ओपन
कर लेता हूं। फुल स्क्रीन में ताकि ये फुल
स्क्रीन में दिख जाए। हां। कुछ इस तरीके
से। ये आ गई हमारी अटैक बॉक्स ओपन हो चुकी
है। ठीक है? अब यहां पे हम इस प्लंक को
ओपन कर लेते हैं। इस प्लंक को ओपन करने के
लिए सिंपल यहां पे क्या करना पड़ेगा भैया?
इस प्लंक को ओपन करने के लिए
ये हमारी आईपी मिली है। ये स्प्लक लैब
मशीन अटैकर मशीन ये है। यह टारगेट मशीन
है। लैब की मशीन जो है हमारी। तो लैब की
मशीन को कॉपी कर लेते हैं आईपी इसकी। ठीक
है? आईपी कॉपी करके हम अटैक बॉक्स में इस
आईपी को ओपन करते हैं।
लेट्स ओपन द आईपी।
यहां पर हमने IP डाली जो हमारा लैब मशीन
था यह स्प्लक को लोड करेगा जो हमने
स्प्लंक पहले भी देखा फॉर स्प्ल
इंटरप्राइज़ ये लोड कर रहा है
एंड लेट्स सी
लेट इट लोड फर्स्ट
क्योंकि यह ऑलरेडी लॉक्ड इन ही ओपन लॉग इन
लॉग इन की जरूरत नहीं है हमें क्योंकि
हमें यहां पे लॉग इन की जरूरत पड़ी थी
आपने देखा होगा तो यहां पे अब इस तरीके का
यहां पे ओपन हो रहा है। ठीक है? यह थोड़ा
सा पुराना वाला वर्जन है इसलिए ऐसा दिख
रहा है। अभी नए वाले लेटेस्ट वर्जन में
कुछ इस तरीके का इंटरफेस हो चुका है। बट
काम वही है। सारा कुछ वही है। सेम चीज है।
अब इस प्लंक में आप देखेंगे तो सबसे ऊपर
वाला जो बार होता है ये वाला बार इसको हम
यहां चलते हैं। इसको हम स्प्लक बार बोलते
हैं। ये आपका स्प्लंक बार है। ये जो ऊपर
वाला बार है जहां पे स्प्लक एंटरप्राइज़
ये जो मैसेजेस हैं, सेटिंग्स हैं,
एक्टिविटी, हेल्प है। ये सारी चीजें इसमें
होती है। मैसेजेस यहां पे आपको अलग-अलग
नोटिफिकेशंस होते हैं। सेटिंग्स में आपको
डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ सेटिंग्स मिल जाती है।
जैसे यूजर की सेटिंग हो गई, रोल्स हो गए,
टोकंस हो गया, सर्वर की सेटिंग हो गई। ये
सारी चीजें हो जाती है। एक्टिविटी में
आपको यहां पे एक्टिविटी से रिलेटेड चीजें
मिल जाएंगी। हर ऐप में डॉक्यूमेंटेशन
वगैरह, प्राइवेसी पॉलिसी ये सब मिल जाएगी।
तो ये आपका स्प्लंग बार हो गया। दूसरा
आपका होता है एप्स पैनल। वो क्या होता है?
वो ये वाला पैनल है। ये जो आपको एप्स का
पैनल मिल रहा है ये वाली। ये एप्स का पैनल
है। जहां पे आपके जितने भी एप्स हैं वो
सारे एप्स यहां पे आपको दिखते हैं जो आप
एप्स यूज़ कर रहे हैं फिलहाल के लिए। ठीक
है? उसके बाद आता है एक्सप्लोर पैनल और ये
जो मेन यहां पे आपको पैनल मिला जिसको आप
यहां पे मिनिमाइज भी कर सकते हैं। ऐसे
करके एक्सप्लोर पैनल होता है जहां से आप
अपने डेटा को ऐड कर कर सकते हैं। इस प्लंक
के अदर एप्लीकेशनेशंस या ऐड ऑन्स को
इंस्टॉल या यूज़ कर सकते हैं और इस प्लंक
के डॉक्यूमेंटेशन को देख सकते हैं। तो ये
तीन तरह की ये चीजें आप यहां से एक्सप्लोर
वाली पैनल से कर सकते हैं। और लास्ट में
आता है स्प्लंक डैशबोर्ड। तो स्प्लंक
डैशबोर्ड जो है वो डैशबोर्ड बेसिकली यहां
पे आपको दिखेगी। अभी फिलहाल आपको यहां पे
डैशबोर्ड जैसा कुछ नहीं दिख रहा है। यहां
पे यहां पे देखो यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं दिख
रहा। ऐसा क्यों दिख रहा? ऐसा क्यों नहीं
दे दिख रहा है यहां पे डैशबोर्ड? क्योंकि
यहां पे जो लिखा हुआ है ना फॉरवर्डर
मॉनिटरिंग इज़ डिसेबल्ड। क्योंकि फॉरवर्डर
मॉनिटरिंग अभी डिसेबल्ड है। तो आपको कोई
सा भी यहां पे डैशबोर्ड टाइप कुछ नहीं दिख
रहा। तो इसको हम इनेबल कर सकते हैं। इसके
लिए क्या करना पड़ेगा? प्लीज गो टू द
सेटअप पेज। तो हमें सेटअप पेज पे चलना है
यहां पे। लेट्स गो टू द सेटअप पेज।
अब सेटअप पेज पर करने के बाद फॉरवर्डिंग
जो है फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्डर मॉनिटरिंग
जो बेसिकली लॉग जो डाटा कलेक्ट करती है वो
ये फॉरवर्डर ही करता है तो फॉरवर्डर तो
इनेबल होना ही चाहिए तो डिसेबल तो इसको हम
इनेबल कर देंगे कितने देर के लिए इनेबल
करना है 15 मिनट कितना मिनट तो मैं यहां
पे 30 मिनट के लिए कर देता हूं फिलहाल के
लिए 30 मिनट्स आई थिंक सफिशिएंट होने
चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से तो मैं 30 मिनट्स के
लिए कर देता हूं एंड यहां पे सेव कर देता
हूं मैंने सेव किया यहां पे फॉरवर्ड
मॉनिटरिंग इज़ एक्टिव यहां पे कर देते हैं
कंटिन्यू कर देते हैं यहां पे इन
प्रोग्रेस हो रहा है डन हो गया यहां और
फॉर ऑर्डर यह जो है आपका एक्टिव हो चुका
है। वापस से हम कहां चलेंगे? हमारे
स्प्लंग एंटरप्राइजेस पे चलेंगे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब जो है आप देखेंगे कि यहां पे एक लोड
करके यहां पे कुछ डिटेल्स आपके आ जाएंगे
और ये डैशबोर्ड आपके सामने यहां पे आ चुका
है। ये पूरा अब डैशबोर्ड आ गया है। दिस इज़
द एक्चुअल डैशबोर्ड जो आपके स्प्लक के
अंदर देखने को मिलेगा। अब यही सेम टूल और
सेम चीजें जो है आपको स्प्लंक के अंदर जो
आप कंपनी में जाएंगे जब आप कंपनी में जॉब
करेंगे जब आप एसओसी एल1 की तरह काम करेंगे
तो आपको इसी तरह का टूल इसी तरह की
इंटरफेस देखने को मिलेगी। ये थोड़ा सा
ओल्ड हो सकता है। ये आपकी जो लेटेस्ट वाली
है ये आपकी लेटेस्ट वाली पैनल जो है वो
है। बेसिकली यहां पे जो आप यहां पे देख
रहे हैं यहां पे स्ल रिपोर्ट्स और ये सब
चीजें सेम तरीके से सेम वो काम करती है।
कोई अलग डिफरेंस नहीं है। कुछ भी नहीं है
यहां पे। यहां पे आप मेन उस पे आएंगे तो
आपको मेन पेज आपको कुछ इस तरीके का दिखेगा
जहां पे बुकमार्क्स है ये आपको डैशबोर्ड
यहां पे आपको डैशबोर्ड यहां पे देखने को
मिल जाता है। यहां पे अलग-अलग ऑप्शंस आ
रहे हैं। सर्च हिस्ट्री यहां पे आपको सर्च
हिस्ट्री देखने को मिल जाएगी। जो जो सर्च
किए हैं रिसेंटली व्यूड में मिल जाएगी।
क्रिएटेड बाय यू शेयरर्ड विद यू सारी
चीजें मिल जाएगी। ठीक है? तो थोड़ा ये
क्लाउड ओरिएंटेड ज्यादा बना दिया गया है।
एंड यहां पे अगेन आपका स्प्लंक बार आपको
देखने को मिल जाएगा। जहां पे आपको हेल्थ
जो स्प्लंक का डिप्लॉयमेंट हुआ है उसका
हेल्थ बताएगा। यहां पे सर्च का है, फाइंड
का है। यहां पे एक्टिविटी है। यहां पे
सेटिंग्स है। जैसे उसमें सेटिंग्स वगैरह
का था वो सब कुछ है। यहां नोटिफिकेशन है।
जो मैसेजेस थे वहां पे एंड यहां पे फर्दर
जो है ऑप्शंस यहां पे देखने को मिल रहे
हैं। राइट? तो थोड़ी बहुत चेंजेस है बस और
कुछ भी नहीं है। बाकी सब सेम ही है। तो इस
तरीके से अब यहां पे डैशबोर्ड आ चुका है।
अब इस डैशबोर्ड में क्या आप कर सकते हैं?
जैसे कि टाइम रेंज देख सकते हैं कि कितने
टाइम रेंज का आपको डिटेल है जो है वह
देखना है। तो लास्ट 4 घंटे की आपको देखनी
है। आपको आज की देखनी है। आपको 1 साल अभी
तक इस साल में अभी तक की देखनी है पूरी 15
मिनट की 60 मिनट की सारी चीजें जो है ना
वो आपको यहां पे देखने को मिल जाएगी। अब
इसमें आप डैशबोर्ड भी ऐसे सेलेक्ट कर सकते
हैं। कैसे? इस सेटिंग्स वाले ऑप्शन पे
जाएंगे तो यहां चेंज डैशबोर्ड का ऑप्शन
मिलेगा। इस पे जब आप क्लिक करेंगे तो आप
यहां पे डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ डैशबोर्ड्स जो
है वो यूज कर सकते हैं। अभी फॉरवर्डस
इंस्टेंस हम यूज़ कर रहे हैं। अभी इसमें
बहुत सारे और डैशबोर्ड के ऑप्शंस आपको मिल
जाएंगे। जैसे कि आप डेटा क्वालिटी यहां पे
आ गया। डैशबोर्ड स्टूडियो आ गया, सीपीयू
यूसेस डेप्लॉयमेंट आ गया, कैस्केटिंग
रेप्लीकेशन आ गया यहां पे। तो देयर आर
मल्टीपल ऑप्शंस जो यू यू कैन यूज़ और यहां
पे आप डैशबोर्ड लिस्टिंग पेज जो है उस पे
भी जाके आप यहां पे डैशबोर्ड्स की पूरी
लिस्टिंग आपको मिल जाएगी। अलग-अलग
डैशबोर्ड्स हैं। आपको जो चाहिए वो यूज़ आप
इसमें से भी कर सकते हैं। देयर आर लॉट ऑफ़
डैशबोर्ड्स 147 डैशबोर्ड्स के टाइप आपको
देख मतलब कि डैशबोर्ड्स क्या है? ये
बेसिकली आपके डेटा को दिखाने का एक तरीका
है। तो आप उसको कैसे देखना चाहते हैं? वो
एक टेंपलेट टाइप है कि हां भैया मैं ऐसे
देखना चाहता हूं। मैं वैसे देखना चाहता
हूं। बस वही चीज़ है। तो ये आप यहां से
बेसिकली कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? तो फिलहाल
हम बैक करते हैं।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
एंड यहां हमारा डैशबोर्ड अभी सिलेक्टेड
है। हमारा डैशबोर्ड जो है यहां पे इस
तरीके से कुछ दिख रहा है। चलिए तो ये
डैशबोर्ड आपकी हो जाती है। तो इन द ऐड अब
यहां पे क्वेश्चन है इन द ऐड डेटा टैब
व्हिच ऑप्शन इज़ यूज्ड टू कलेक्ट डेटा
फ्रॉम फाइल्स एंड पोर्ट्स। फाइल्स एंड
पोर्ट्स से कौन सी डेटा कलेक्ट की जाती
है? किस तरीके की? तो हम यहां पे ऐड डेटा
पे जब क्लिक करेंगे तो हमें ऑप्शन मिल
जाता है डेटा को यहां पे जो लॉग्स हैं
उनको ऐड करने का। तो इस तरीके से ही आप
लॉग्स को या जो भी इनपुट डेटा है, जो भी
आपका रॉ डेटा है, उसको आप ऐड करते हैं।
ठीक है? स्प्लक के अंदर में तो स्प्लक
आपको वैरायटी ऑफ़ ऑप्शंस देता है डेटा को
जो भी लॉग्स है उसको ऐड करने का। अब जब वो
डेटा ऐड होगी जो लॉग ऐड होगी तभी तो
स्प्लंक का फर्दर प्रोसेससेस होगा ना?
क्योंकि जो कंटेनर कंटेनर होता है आपका जो
फॉरवर्डर होता है वो डेटा कलेक्ट करता है।
ठीक है? तो अलग-अलग तरीके से कलेक्शन हो
सकती है। एक एंड पॉइंट पे ऑटोमेटिक
कलेक्शन हो सकती है। आप डेट उसको दे भी
सकते हो फॉर ऑर्डर को। लो भाई डेटा ये डेट
हमने दी। अब इस पे फर्दर प्रोसेसिंग करो
और एक सर्चेबल जो है एक पूरा का पूरा
डेटाबेस बना के हमें दे दो। ठीक है? राइट?
अब यहां पे [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
आते हैं।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे नीचे आते हैं यहां पे। अब स्प्लंक
के अंदर में हम क्लाउड कंप्यूटिंग के थ्रू
डेटा को इंसर्ट कर सकते हैं। जैसे कि गेट
योर क्लाउड कंप्यूटिंग डेटा इंटू स्प्ल
प्लेटफार्म। क्लाउड कंप्यूटिंग के थ्रू
नेटवर्किंग के थ्रू गेट योर नेटवर्किंग
डेटा इंटू स्प्ल। तो नेटवर्किंग के थ्रू
भी हम डेटा डाल सकते हैं। ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
गेट योर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डेटा इंटू स्प्ल
प्लेटफार्म। आप ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के थ्रू
भी डेटा आप इसमें डाल सकते हैं।
सिक्योरिटी गेट और सिक्योरिटी डेटा अगर
सिक्योरिटी लॉक्स हैं तो सिक्योरिटी डेटा
के थ्रू डाल सकते हैं। इसके अलावा स्प्लक
आपको और भी ऑप्शंस प्रोवाइड करता है। जैसे
अपलोड आप डायरेक्टली अपने कंप्यूटर से
लोकल फाइल्स की फॉर्मेट में अपलोड कर सकते
हैं। जैसे मान लो सीएसबी फाइल में डेटा
आपके पास पड़ी है। आप इसमें अपलोड कर
दीजिए। उससे भी हो जाएगा। मॉनिटर फाइल्स
एंड पोर्ट्स ऑन दिस स्प्लंक प्लेटफार्म
इंस्टेंसेस। फाइल्स कौन सी जैसे एस
एचटीटीपी डब्ल्यूएमआई टीसीपी यूडीपी
स्क्रिप्ट्स हो गए मॉड्यूलर इनपुट्स फॉर
एक्सटर्नल डाटा सोर्सेस मतलब जो भी फाइल्स
एंड पोर्ट्स मतलब एक पोर्ट पे ये आपका काम
करता रहेगा एक पोर्ट पे आपका इसका जो
फॉरवर्डर है वो बैठ जाएगा उसी पोर्ट पे
डेटा को लिसन करता रहेगा जो भी डेटा उस
पोर्ट पे आप भेजेंगे वो यहां पे अपलोड हो
जाएगी वो यहां पे आ जाएगी उसके बाद यहां
पे फॉरवर्डर डेटा फ्रॉम अ स्प्लक फॉरवर्डर
कोई और फॉरवर्डर जैसे है वहां से आप डाटा
डालना चाहते हैं तो वहां से भी आप डाल
सकते हैं। तो यहां पे क्वेश्चन यही था कि
कि कौन सा ऑप्शन यूज़ किया जाता है डेटा को
कलेक्ट करने के लिए फ्रॉम फाइल्स एंड
पोर्ट्स। तो मॉनिटर मॉनिटर ऑप्शन तो यहां
पे मॉनिटर लिख दो। सिंपल ये प्रीमियम रूम
है इसलिए मैं थोड़ा सा आपके लिए कर दे रहा
हूं। यहां पे मॉनिटर लिख दो।
दैट्स इट। ठीक है? ओके। दैट्स इट। बस ये
इतना ही। इसमें तो इतना ही था। अब यहां पे
मेन हम एडिंग डाटा पे आते हैं। मेन हमारा
जो मेन वह चीज है वह एडिंग डाटा है। इसमें
आपको चीजें देखने को मिलेगी इंटरेस्टिंग
चीजें। स्प्लंक कैन इंजेस्ट एनी डेटा। ये
स्प्लक जो है ना किसी भी तरह का डेटा ऐड
कर सकता है। अकॉर्डिंग टू द स्प्लंक
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन व्हेन डेटा इज़ एडेड टू
स्प्लंक। जब डेटा को स्प्लंक में ऐड किया
जाता है। द डेटा इज़ प्रोसेस्ड एंड
ट्रांसफॉर्म्ड इंटू अ सीरीज़ ऑफ़ इंडिविजुअल
इवेंट्स। डेटा को एक सीरीज़ ऑफ़ इंडिविजुअल
इवेंट्स में प्रोसेस किया जाता है टाइम
स्टैंप के थ्रू। अभी मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा कि
ये टाइम स्टैंप में कैसे डेटा आपके सामने
आती है। टाइम स्टेप में कैसे डेट आपके पास
आती है। द डेटा सोर्सर्सेस कैन बी इवेंट
लॉक्स। डेटा सोर्सेस क्या-क्या हो सकते
हैं? इवेंट लॉक्स हो सकते हैं, वेबसाइट के
लॉक्स होते हैं। फायर लॉक्स हो सकते हैं,
वीpए लॉक्स हो सकते हैं। सिक्योरिटी लॉक्स
होते हैं। किसी भी तरह का उनको डिवाइड
किया गया है। तो अब मैं यहां पे ना
स्प्लंक का डॉक्यूमेंटेशन एक बार ओपन करता
हूं। शायद स्प्लp्ल का डॉक्यूमेंटेशन का
लिंक होगा। हां। ये स्प्ल का ऑफिशियल
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन है। ठीक है? यह देखिए स्प्ल
की वेबसाइट पर dx.plunk.com
पे इस पे आप आके इसकी डॉक्यूमेंटेशन पूरी
देख सकते हैं। इसमें मैं यहां पे अपलोडिंग
डेटा ट्यूटोरियल पे चलते हैं। अबाउट
अपलोडिंग डेटा इस पे चलते हैं। और यहीं पे
आपको मिलेगी व्हाट काइंड ऑफ़ डेटा यू कैन
अपलोड। तो आप देखेंगे यहां पे कि इन जनरल
डेटा सोर्सेस आर ग्रुप्ड इनू फॉलोइंग
कैटेगरीज। इन कैटेगरीज़ में डिवाइड किए गए।
तो आप देखेंगे इसमें सारी तरह के डाटा आप
अपलोड कर सकते हैं। फ़ाइल्स एंड
डायरेक्टरीज़ अपलोड से फ़ाइल्स एंड
डायरेक्टरी से रिलेटेड जो भी डाटा है
लॉक्स हैं उसको नेटवर्क इवेंट्स के जो भी
लॉक्स हैं उसको आईटी ऑपरेशन से रिलेटेड है
उसको क्लाउड सर्विसेस से रिलेटेड भी कर
सकते हैं। डेटाबेस सर्विज से रिलेटेड भी
कर सकते हैं। सिक्योरिटी सर्विज से भी कर
सकते हैं। वर्चुअलाइजेशन सर्विज से भी कर
सकते हैं। एप्लीकेशन सर्विस के थ्रू का भी
कर सकते हैं। Windows सोर्सेस का कर सकते
हैं। अदर सोर्सेस मतलब हर तरह के सोर्सेस
डेटा को जो है आप यहां पे अपलोड कर सकते
हैं। इसमें सारी इन चीजों को आप पढ़ सकते
हैं। कौन-कौन से किस तरह के डेटा है। तो
हम आप इसमें अब कर सकते हैं। चलिए
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] चलते हैं
डेटा ऐड करने का एडिंग डेटा वाले पे। अब
यहां पे देखिए
इस टास्क में इन्होंने वीpए logs पे फोकस
किया है। ठीक है? वीpए log्स। तो यहां पे
किस तरीके से यूज़ किया है? यहां पे ऐड
डेटा ये करेंगे। कहां से करेंगे?
वी विल यूज़ द अपलोड ऑप्शन टू अपलोड द डेटा
फ्रॉम आवर लोकल मशीन। तो ये लोकल मशीन से
डेटा अपलोड करने का ऑप्शन यूज करेंगे।
हालांकि आपके पास बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस हैं।
क्या-क्या ऑप्शंस हैं? मैंने पहले ही बता
दिया है। मशीन से कीजिए। मॉनिटर एक पोर्ट
के थ्रू मॉनिटर कीजिए। अलग फॉर ऑर्डर से
कीजिए। या फिर आप क्लाउड कंप्यूटिंग
नेटवर्किंग का ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम या
सिक्योरिटी के थ्रू सिक्योरिटी लॉक्स ये
सबको डायरेक्टली यहां पे कर दीजिए। जैसे
मान लो कि यहां पे क्लाउड कंप्यूटिंग के
थ्रू है। तो क्लिक आप जब करेंगे तो आपको
इसकी डिटेल्स आएगी कि क्लाउड कंप्यूटर के
थ्रू किसके किसके लॉक्स आप बेसिकली इसमें
करना चाहते हैं। एडब्ल्यूएस की एडब्ल्यूएस
बिलिंग की से रिलेटेड डेट आपको यहां पे
लॉक करना है। AWS क्लाउड फ्रंट की करनी
है। AWS कॉन्फ़िग की करनी है। AWS ईएलबी
एक्सेस लॉक्स की करनी है। S3 का करना है।
आपको Amazon kines Amazon वेब सर्विस का
ये सारी चीजें आपको यहां पे क्लाउड वाली
मिल जाएगी। तो AWS से इंटीग्रेटेड है यहां
पे। उसी तरीके से अगर आप नेटवर्किंग के
लॉग्स कनेक्ट करना चाहते हैं तो यहां पे
दो सोर्सर्सेस हैं Sisco एडप्टेड
सिक्योरिटी नेट नेटवर्किंग का ये है आपका
Po Alto नेटवर्क्स ये दो Sisco और Palo
Alto नेटवर्क्स को ये बेसिकली सपोर्ट कर
रहे हैं। अब यहां पे जो ये लॉक्स जैसे ये
जो
अ अपलोड वाली सोर्सेस है। अब यहां पे जो
बेसिकली यहां पे जैसे ये है ना अ डिटेल्स
यहां पे सर्च एंड रिपोर्टिंग ये वाली जो
ऑप्शन है। तो यहां पर भी आपको अलग-अलग
डिटेल्स यहां पर मिल जाएंगे। यहां पर सर्च
एंड रिपोर्टिंग में।
ठीक है? आप यहां पे सर्च वगैरह तो कर सकते
हैं। सारी चीजें कर सकते हैं। यहां पे मैं
डैशबोर्ड पे चलता हूं पहले।
और यहां पे हम क्या करते हैं?
डाटा एक सेकंड रुक जाइए।
जस्ट अ सेकंड
हम डाटा सेट्स पर चलते हैं। एक चीज आपको
दिखाने की कोशिश करता हूं। इफ
इफ यह पॉसिबल हुआ यहां पे मिल जाए मुझे
कुछ तो। यह तो कुछ सैंपल है। उस पे अभी
नहीं जाएंगे।
नहीं इसमें तो नहीं है मॉड्यूल्स पे चलो
इसमें एक बार करते हैं।
ओके यहां पे क्या आ रहा है? अनेबल टू
प्रोसेस एसएल टू मॉड्यूल्स। ये क्यों आ
रहा है भाई?
अनेबल टू प्रोसेस ऐसा क्यों भाई चलो ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं है वो नहीं आ रहा है बट
यहां पे अगर मैं ऑप्शन देखूं तो शायद यहां
पे इन्होंने ऐड कुछ और अगर किया हो तो नए
वाले में मैं स्किप कर देता हूं फिलहाल के
लिए देखते हैं नहीं अभी भी वही चीज है
यहां पे भी 10 मैं यहां पे देख रहा था
शायद इन्होंने नए वाले वर्जन में कुछ नए
एडिशन किए होंगे तो आप यहां पे देखोगे कि
यहां भी क्लाउड कंप्यूटिंग में भी 10 डेटा
सोर्सर्सेस हैं। नेटवर्किंग में दो हैं।
इसमें एक है इसमें तीन है। यहां पे भी
ऑलमोस्ट सेम है। नए वाले में भी 10 2 एक
और तीन डाटा सोर्सर्सेस यहां पे 10 में
अगर देखा तो शायद एडब्ल्यूएस वाले ही हैं
होंगे सारे तो क्लाउड कंप्यूटिंग में यस
एडब्ल्यूएस वाले ही यहां पे सारे अभी भी
प्रेजेंट है। ठीक है? तो दोनों सेम ही है।
मुझे लगता है कि कुछ हो सकता है नए वाले
में कुछ नया डेटा सोर्स ऐड किया हो। ठीक
है? तो अब यहां पे टास्क के अकॉर्डिंग
हमें अपलोड करना है यहां पे मैनुअली अपने
सिस्टम से। तो ये अटैक बॉक्स है। तो
बेसिकली इन्होंने क्या किया है? टास्क
फाइल दिया हुआ है। यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं टास्क फाइल दिया है। जब आप डाउनलोड पे
क्लिक करेंगे डाउनलोड टास्क फाइल तो यह
टास्क फाइल डाउनलोड हो जाएगी जो कि एक
बेसिकली jसon फाइल है। आप देख सकते हैं
वीpए log json फाइल ये कुछ भी नहीं है। आप
देखेंगे यहां पे तो ये एक jसon फाइल है
वीpए वीpए logs की बस और कुछ भी नहीं है।
ठीक है? तो यहां पे मैं क्या करूंगा? मैं
क्योंकि एक अटैक बॉक्स के अंदर में हूं तो
यहां पे इन्होंने क्या लिख रखा है कि अगर
आप अटैक बॉक्स यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो इस
डायरेक्टरी में ऑलरेडी ये फाइल प्रेजेंट
है इस रूट के अंदर रूम्स के अंदर में
स्प्ल बेसिक्स के अंदर में तो चलो मैं
वहीं से अपलोड करूंगा तो मैं यहां पे
अपलोड पे क्लिक करता हूं एंड लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग
ओके तो अब मेरे मशीन पे मैं देख लेता हूं
यहां पे भैया ये कौन सा है अच्छा ये मेन
मेन वाली उस पे आ गया है क्या ये मेन वाली
पे आग है इसको इसको चलो इसको इधर कर देते
हैं। यहां से मैं अपलोड करता हूं। यहां पे
अपलोड करूंगा। तो अपलोड करने के बाद अपलोड
पे क्लिक जब आप करोगे तो यहां पे आएगा
फाइल को सेलेक्ट करने के लिए। तो मेरा
फाइल यहां पे फिलहाल मशीन पे कहां पे है?
तो रूट के अंदर में यहां पे अ रूम्स के
अंदर में एंड यहां पे स्प्लंक स्प्लंक
कहां है भैया? स्प्लक स्प्लंक स्प्लक
बेसिक्स के अंदर में ये रहा वीpए lock.
JSON ये फाइल यहां पे प्रेजेंट है। इस
मशीन के अंदर में इसी फाइल को मैं सेलेक्ट
करने वाला हूं। तो चलिए मैं यहां पे
सेलेक्ट फाइल करता हूं। एंड यहां पे मैं
सेलेक्ट कर लेता हूं रूम्स होम के अंदर
में रूम्स के अंदर में एंड यहां पे स्प्लक
बेसिक्स एंड देन वीpए log एंड देन
सेलेक्ट। तो हमने फाइल यहां पे अपलोड कर
दी है। वीpए logs फाइल यहां पे आ चुका है।
राइट? वी आर नाउ गुड टू गो। अब यहां पे
हमें नेक्स्ट करना है। अभी अभी यहां पे
खत्म नहीं हुआ आपको। अभी आपको जब आप कोई
भी लॉग की फाइल अपलोड करोगे उसके बाद और
भी चीजें हैं जो करनी है। नेक्स्ट पे
क्लिक करेंगे। नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक करने के
बाद यहां पे अब आपको फॉर्मेट चूज़ करना है।
तो यहां पे ऑलरेडी फॉर्मेट ऑलरेडी सेलेक्ट
हो चुका है। jसon फॉर्मेट यहां पे क्योंकि
Jसon हमारा फॉर्मेट था ही। JSON फाइल थी।
बट आप यहां पे अपने अकॉर्डिंग फॉर्मेट
चेंज कर सकते हो। जैसे इस फॉर्मेट में
आपको कौन सा फॉर्मेट आपका जो फाइल है वो
है। जैसे अब एप्लीकेशन के फॉर्मेट में
आपको बहुत सारे एप्लीकेशन फॉर्मेट मिल
जाएंगे। डेटाबेस फॉर्मेट में आपको सॉरी
मायesक्यूएल का भी मिल जाएगा आपको यहां पे
मायesक्यूएलl डाटा फॉर्मेट जो है वो सारी
चीजें मिल जाएंगी। ईमेल फॉर्मेट में ईमेल
के अलग-अलग फॉर्मेट्स मिल जाएंगे। लॉक टू
मैट्रिक्स फॉर्मेट्स में मैट्रिक्स
फॉर्मेट्स, मिसलेनियस फॉर्मेट्स मिल
जाएंगे। नेटवर्क एंड सिक्योरिटी फॉर्मेट्स
में स्नॉट और sisco का आपको मिल जाएगा।
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम फॉर्मेट में आपको अलग-अलग
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम फॉर्मेट यहां पे Windows
और Linux दोनों के मिल जाएंगे। स्ट्रक्चर
फॉर्मेट में ऑप्शन मिलता है आपको। jसon का
सीएसv का इवेंट लॉक्स का ईट इवेंट लॉक्स
jसon नो टाइम स्टैंप का यहां पे अलग-अलग
फॉर्मेट्स यहां पे स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वाले में
तो हमारा स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वाला ही है jसon है
तो jसon यहां पे सिलेक्टेड है तो अभी
फिलहाल यहां पे हमें कुछ नहीं करना jसon
सेक्टेड है वी विल क्लिक ऑन नेक्स्ट अब जब
आप नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक करेंगे तो आपको यहां
पे कुछ इनपुट सेटिंग्स जो है वो आपको यहां
पे डिफाइन करनी होती है। उसमें दो
सेटिंग्स होती है। एक आपका होस्ट है और एक
आपका इंडेक्स है। तो एक आपको क्या करना
होता है? होस्ट की वैल्यू आपको डिफाइन
करनी होती है। क्या होता है ये? व्हेन द
स्प्लंक प्लेटफार्म इंडेक्सेस डेटा। जब
डेटा को स्प्लंक इंडेक्स करता है, ईच
इवेंट रिसीव्स अ होस्ट वैल्यू। हर इवेंट
जो है एक होस्ट वैल्यू रिसीव करता है कि
भैया ये कौन से होस्ट की पर्टिकुलर लॉग
है। द होस्ट वैल्यू शुड बी द नेम ऑफ़ द
मशीन फ्रॉम व्हिच द इवेंट ओरिजिनेट्स।
होस्ट वैल्यू में आपका मशीन का नाम होना
चाहिए। आइडियली मशीन का नाम होना चाहिए।
ठीक है? द टाइप ऑफ़ इनपुट यूज़। तो अब यहां
पे मशीन का नाम दे देते हैं। तो मैं यहां
पे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
मशीन करके नाम दे देता हूं। कोई भी ठीक
है? यह कर देंगे। और यहां पे उसके बाद है
इंडेक्स। अब यहां पे क्या है? द प्लंक
प्लेटफार्म स्टोर्स इनकमिंग डेटा एज
इवेंट्स इन द सिलेक्टेड इंडेक्स। कंसीडर
यूजिंग अ सैंडबॉक्स इंडेक्स। ठीक है?
सैंडbox इंडेक्स यूज़ कीजिए। अगर लाइक आपको
अगर अलग से यूज़ करने का मन नहीं है मतलब
एक सेफ एनवायरमेंट के अंदर में। अदरवाइज
आप यहां पे एक इंडेक्स का नाम क्रिएट कर
सकते हैं। खुद का इंडेक्स क्रिएट कर सकते
हैं। तो मैं यहां पे क्रिएट अ न्यू
इंडेक्स पे क्लिक करता हूं। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे
इंडेक्स का नाम देना है। तो मैं कर देता
हूं वीpn लॉग्स।
ठीक है? वीpए लॉक्स मैंने इंडेक्स का नाम
दे दिया। बाकी चीजें जो है आप एज़ इट इज़
छोड़ सकते हैं। ये सारी चीजें ऑप्शनल है।
इसमें कोई रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है आपको कुछ
भी चेंज करने की। और यहां पे सेव कर देते
हैं। तो यहां पे अब वीpए lock इंडेक्स बन
चुका है। यहां पे यह सेलेक्ट भी हमने कर
लिया है। तो वीpए lock इंडेक्स हैंड हैज़
बीन क्रिएटेड। ठीक है?
गॉट इट? चलिए अब यहां पे जब सारी चीजें हो
गई तो अब रिव्यू करेंगे। रिव्यू पर क्लिक
करेंगे। तो अब आ गया इनपुट फाइल हमने
अपलोड फाइल वाली सेलेक्ट की है। उसके बाद
फाइल नेम हमने वीpए log डॉट json ये फाइल
नेम दी है। सोर्स टाइप हमने json दिया है।
होस्ट हमारा डिफ़्रॉनिक्स मशीन है। वो हमने
दे दिया है। इंडेक्स हमारा वीpए log्स नाम
से है। दैट्स इट। अब यहां पे हम सबमिट
करेंगे। अब जब सबमिट हम करेंगे तो यहां पे
मैं एक बार टाइम आउट डाल देता हूं इनको जो
अब यहां पे जब हमने सबमिट किया तो अब यहां
पे क्या हो रहा है नाउ द फाइल हैज़ बीन
अपलोडेड सक्सेसफुली अब आप एज एन एसओसी एल1
आपने फाइल को अपलोड कर दिया है एंड यहां
पे अब स्टार्ट सर्चिंग का ऑप्शन आ रहा है।
आपने डेटा डाल दिया लॉक डाल दिया। अब आप
उस लॉग के अंदर में सर्च कर सकते हैं।
यहां पे एग्जांपल्स एंड ट्यूटोरियल्स आपको
देखने को बेसिकली मिल जाएंगे। इफ यू वांट
यू कैन विजिट दिस एग्जांपल इन
ट्यूटोरियल्स यहां पे या ओपन हो के आपके
सामने आ जाएगा। जैसे कि ये स्पेशल जो
ट्यूटोरियल्स हैं बेसिकली जो ऑफिशियल जो
डॉक्यूमेंट्स हैं डॉक्स है वो आपको यहां
पे देखने को मिल जाएगा इस प्लंक के। इसमें
सर्चिंग का ट्यूटोरियल सारी चीजें बहुत
डिटेल में दी हुई है। क्वेरीज़ वगैरह के
बारे में सब कुछ दिया हुआ है। तो अब यहां
पे स्टार्ट सर्चिंग पे हम क्लिक करेंगे।
तो हमने स्टार्ट सर्चिंग पे क्लिक किया।
एंड नाउ वी गॉट द डेटा पॉपुलेटेड। हम
हमारे पास डेटा जो है सारी पॉपुलेट हो रही
है। अब देखो यही डेटा इसी तरीके से ये
पॉपुलेट होती है। इफ आई कैन
लेट से इफ आई कैन डू सम फुल स्क्रीन मोड
हां हो गई फुल स्क्रीन मोड हो गई है। चलिए
तो यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके से अब यही आपका
वो सर्च हेड है। सर्च हेड जिसके बारे में
मैंने बात करी थी ना सर्च हेड ये वही सर्च
हेड है जहां से आप आप डेटा को सर्च कर
सकते हैं फाइंड कर सकते हैं। सो दिस इज़
ट्रूली अमेजिंग दिस इज़ इंटरेस्टिंग गाइस
राइट? तो अब यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
मैंने बताया था ना कि हर लॉग के एंट्री को
एक एक टाइम स्टैंप इवेंट्स की तरह एक
इंडिविजुअल इवेंट्स की तरह ये लिस्ट करता
है। तो देखिए इंडिविजुअल इवेंट्स की तरह
लिस्टिंग हो रही है यहां पे। जैसे यह
देखिए यहां पे डेट आपका दिया हुआ है। टाइम
एग्जैक्ट टाइम स्टैंप दिया हुआ है। और
उसकी पूरी जो अंदर की डिटेल्स है वो दी
हुई है। जैसे कंपनी कौन सी है? इवेंट टाइम
क्या है? सोर्स कंट्री क्या है? सोर्स
आईपी, यूजरनेम क्या है? एक्शन क्या है?
इंडेक्स, पोर्ट नंबर, प्रोटोकॉल, सोर्स
स्टेट ये सारी चीजें दी हुई है। ठीक है?
आप शो एज़ रॉ टेक्स्ट करेंगे तो आपको एज़ रॉ
टेक्स्ट भी यहां पे मिल जाएगा। एंड शो
सिंटेक्स हाईलाइटेड तो सिंटेक्स हाइलाइटेड
भी मिल जाएगा। सारी चीजें रॉ टेक्स्ट में
तो रॉ फॉर्मेट में भी आपको इस तरह दिख
जाएगी jसon का और इस तरीके से भी आपको दिख
जाएगी। तो कुछ इस तरीके से टाइम स्टैंप
वाइज ये सारी चीजें जो है आपको ला के देता
है। ये आप देख सकते हैं टाइम स्टैंप वाइज।
ये 6:27 ये सबसे लेटेस्ट वाला जो है वो
लेटेस्ट टाइम का होता है। और प्रीवियस
टाइम के उसके नीचे आपको देखने को मिलेंगे।
तो ये आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे टोटल। अब
मुझे ये चीज देख के यह ऊपर यह पूरी
स्क्रीन देखके मुझे बताइए। मैं यहां पे
ज़ूम आउट करके और छोटा कर देता हूं। ज़ूम
आउट। हां, ताकि आपको अच्छे से दिखेगी।
बेसिकली ज़ूम अ ज़ूम आउट का ये ग्राफ से
मतलब है। मुझे बताइए यहां पे टोटल कितने
इवेंट्स हैं इस पर्टिकुलर लॉक्स के अंदर
में? इस स्क्रीन को देख के आप ही लोग सभी
लोग आंसर कीजिए। हाउ मेनी इवेंट्स आर देयर
इन दिस पर्टिकुलर सर्च रिजल्ट? जो सर्चिंग
सर्च डेटाबेस बनी है उस लॉग फाइल से कितने
इवेंट्स हैं?
एवरीवन प्लीज रिप्लाई।
आई एम वेटिंग फॉर द रिस्पांस। सही गलत जो
भी है आई एम वेटिंग फॉर द रिस्पांस।
बताइए
2862 बिल्कुल सही जवाब है। एंड आई थिंक
फर्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ दिस कि अपलोड द डेटा
वीपीए लॉक्स एंड हाउ मेनी इवेंट्स आर
प्रेजेंट? तो 2862
करेक्ट। अब यहां पे क्वेश्चन है हाउ मेनी
लॉग इवेंट्स आर कैप्चरर्ड बाय द यूजर
मैलीना?
यूजर मैलीना के द्वारा कितने लॉग इवेंट्स
जो है कैप्चर हुए हैं? तो अब इसके लिए आप
इस पर्टिकुलर स्पंक डैशबोर्ड पे आप आएंगे
तो यहां पे आपको लेफ्ट साइड में ना
फील्ड्स दिखेंगे। अलग-अलग होस्ट, सोर्स,
सोर्स टाइप, इंटरेस्टिंग अ फील्ड्स में
आपको अलग-अलग जैसे एक्शन, डेट, मंथ, मिनट,
डे ये सब चीज मिलेंगी। और इसी में आपको
यूजरनेम्स भी मिलेगा। तो मैं यूजरनेम्स पे
क्लिक करूंगा और यहां पे आप देखेंगे मैना।
मेलना के टोटल कितने काउंट्स हैं? टोटल
कितने यहां पे काउंट्स हो रहे हैं? 60। तो
ठीक है यहां पे 60 आंसर है। 60 इवेंट्स।
[संगीत]
दैट्स इट। व्हाट इज द यूजरनेम एसोसिएटेड
विद द आईपी 1071418238
अब यहां पर आ रहा है कि इस आईपी से
एसोसिएटेड यूजरनेम कौन सा है? क्या
यूजरनेम है इनका? अब ये पता हम कैसे
करेंगे? तो इसके लिए स्प्लक के अंदर में
डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ क्वेरीज होती है। स्प्लक
जो है वो जो आप उसमें सर्च करते हो। ठीक
है? सर्च वह एसएल के थ्रू होती है। एसएल
एक सर्च क्वरी क्वरी को सर्च करने का एक
लैंग्वेज एक तरीका होता है। एसएल क्वरीज
को सर्च करने का वे होता है जिससे कि आप
बहुत लार्ज नंबर ऑफ डेटा सेट के अंदर में
क्वरीज़ को सर्च करते हो। तो हमें वो
एसक्यूएल एसएल सॉरी एसएल एसएल क्वरीज़ को
यूज़ करनी है। तो अलग-अलग जैसे कि आप वायरस
शार्क के अंदर में क्वरीज़ को यूज़ करते हो।
एसक्यूएल एसक्यूएल में क्वरीज को यूज़ करते
हो डेटा को फच करने के लिए। वैसे ही इसके
अंदर एसएल एक क्वरी लैंग्वेज सर्चिंग मेथड
है। उसका यूज़ करके क्वेरीज़ डाल के आप सर्च
करते हो। तो अब मुझे एक IP पता है। अब
मुझे सर्च करनी है कि कौन सा यूजरनेम है
इस IPपी से एसोसिएटेड? तो मैं यहां पे जो
ऊपर सर्च का यहां पे ये पैनल है इसी में
मैं क्या करूंगा? यहां पे डालूंगा सोर्स
देखो सोर्स
आईपी। देखते हैं कोई है सोर्स आईपी। सोर्स
अंडरस्कोर आईपी देखो ये आ रही है सोर्स
अंडरस्कोर आईपी मैंने सोर्स आईपी किया और
यहां पे हम आईपी के जगह पे अपनी आईपी जो
हमें डालनी है वो डाल देंगे जो हमारा दिया
हुआ है ये आईपी हमने डाला सोर्स आईपी तो
हम अब इसको फ़्टर करेंगे अब हम एंटर करेंगे
तो जब हम एंटर करेंगे तो हमारी इस आईपी से
रिलेटेड इनेशन आ जाएगी जो कि आप देख सकते
हैं इस आईपी से जितनी भी इनेशन इस आईपी से
रिलेटेड जितने भी इवेंट्स हैं टोटल
इवेंट्स आ रहे हैं टोटल कितने इवेंट्स आ
रहे हैं 26 इवेंट्स आर एसोसिएटेड विद दिस
IP एड्रेस तो यहां पे सारे इवेंट्स आ गए।
अब हमें देखना है भैया कौन सा यूजर है। तो
आप देखेंगे यहां पे यूजर है स्मिथ। एस एम
आई टी एच। ये स्मिथ जो है यही एसोसिएटेड
है। तो हमारा आंसर हो जाएगा स्मिथ।
दैट्स इट। हो गया सिंपल। अब आते हैं व्हाट
इज द नंबर ऑफ़ इवेंट्स दैट ओरिजिनेटेड
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] फ्रॉम ऑल
कंट्रीज एक्सेप्ट फ्रांस। अब देखो यहां पर
भी अब क्वेश्चन बहुत ही घुमा के है कि
टोटल नंबर ऑफ इवेंट्स बताओ जो सारे
कंट्रीज हो फ्रांस को छोड़ के। सारे
कंट्रीज हो फ्रांस को छोड़ के। तो अब यहां
पे सिंपल सा फंडा है। यहां पे हम फिर से
क्वरी डालेंगे और अब हम यहां पे सोर्स
आईपी नहीं करेंगे। हम यहां पे सोर्स
कंट्री जैसी कुछ है। सोर्स कंट्री है। तो
हम सोर्स कंट्री डालते हैं। अब सोर्स
कंट्री में हमारा फ्रांस है।
सोर्स कंट्री [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
में हमने फ्रांस डाला है। लेकिन यहां पे
क्वेश्चन क्या है कि ये फ्रांस से नहीं
होना चाहिए। वो इवेंट्स के हमें डालने
हैं। नॉट फ्रॉम फ्रांस। तो ये हम अगर
इक्वल टू डालेंगे ना तो ये मतलब कि ये
फ्रांस का दिखाओ। हम जब ये सोर्स कंट्री
फ्रांस डालेंगे और हम एंटर करेंगे तो
फ्रांस से जो इवेंट्स है वो दिखाओ। तो ये
है 48। फ्रांस से जो इवेंट्स है वो 48 है।
बट यहां पे क्या हमारा आंसर 48 होगा? तो
मैं अगर 48 करता हूं ये तो है ही नहीं। ये
तो होगा ही नहीं यार। गलत है ये तो टू
शॉर्ट है यहां पे। तो अब हम यहां पे हमें
यहां आ रहा है कि फ्रांस का ना हो
एक्सेप्ट फ्रांस बाकी सब जगह से हो तो
यहां पे इक्वल्स टू के पहले एक
एक्सक्लेमेशन मार्क लगा देंगे। ये नॉट
इक्वल टू का सिंबल होता है। जब इक्वल टू
के पहले आप एक्सक्लेमेशन लगाते हो तो दैट
रिप्रेजेंट्स नॉट इक्वल टू यानी कि सोर्स
कंट्री सारे हो बट नॉट इक्वल टू फ्रांस।
फ्रांस नहीं होना चाहिए। अब मैं एंटर
करूंगा तो यहां पे 2814 2814 ऑप्शन आ रहा
है। तो 2814 यहां पे हम करेंगे और एंटर कर
देंगे। एंड इट्स सॉल्व बस अब यहां आ रहा
है हाउ मेनी वीपीए इवेंट्स वेयर एसोसिएटेड
विद आईपी एड्रेस ये कितने वीpए इवेंट्स जो
है एसोसिएटेड हैं? तो भैया इस IPपी एड्रेस
से अगेन वही सेम चीज सोर्स IP सोर्स IP कर
लो। यह तो सेम है फंडा। तो सोर्स
IP
एंड अगेन IPपी फॉर्मेट अपना दे देते हैं।
और जो IP है वह IP डाल देते हैं यहां पे।
बस सिंपल एंटर कर देते हैं। कितने वीpए
इवेंट्स हैं? देखो 14 14 इवेंट्स हैं।
क्योंकि ये वीpए लॉग ही है तो सारे वीpए
के ही इवेंट्स हैं। वीpए ही तो लॉग है।
हां अगर वीpए लॉग नहीं होता फिर वीpए
इवेंट्स होता तो फिर इसमें हम अदर क्वेरीज़
फिर कुछ ऐड करते। क्योंकि ये वीpए लॉग है
तो वीpए इवेंट्स 14 है भैया। तो यहां हमने
यहां पे 14 डाला। हमने यहां पे चेक किया।
दैट्स इट। हमारा करेक्ट आंसर है। हो गया।
खत्म कहानी। यहां पे तो कुछ है ही नहीं।
तो यहां पे चेक कर देते हैं।
हो गया। दैट्स इट। खत्म। ये पूरी ये पूरी
चीज थी। तो ये आपका जो है स्प्लंक था जो
आपको मैंने यहां पे स्प्लक के बारे में
बताई। ये स्प्लक की एक ओवरव्यू थी। बट
यहां पे बात यहां स्प्लंक की यहीं पे खत्म
नहीं होती है। देखिए अब मैं यहां पे आपको
गो टू डैशबोर्ड पे क्लिक करता हूं। फिलहाल
के लिए
व्यू पाथ पे क्लिक करते हैं।
एंड यहां पे स्प्लंक वाली पे चलते हैं।
स्प्लंक बेसिक्स पे कंक्लूजन पे चलते हैं।
हियर वी आर गोइंग टू हियर। अब देखिए
यहां पे स्प्लक जब आप यह वाली रूम कंप्लीट
करेंगे। यह प्रीमियम रूम है। ठीक है? मैं
आपको एक टास्क देता हूं। आई आई वांट
एवरीबॉडी टू कंप्लीट द टास्क। क्योंकि यह
बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है फॉर योर दिस एसओसी
एल1 सीरीज। ठीक है? यह याद रखिएगा सभी लोग
ट्राई हैक मी पे अकाउंट क्रिएट कर लीजिएगा
फ्री अकाउंट फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट कोई पैसा नहीं
लगता है एंड यहां पे एक रूम है स्प्लंक
एक्सप्लोरिंग द एसएल ये एक रूम है सर्च जो
ये इसको मैं ओपन कर लेता हूं सर्च क्वरी
लैंग्वेज जो होती है बेसिकली तो यह जो
आपका रूम है यह आपका जो रूम है इसको ओपन
कर लीजिएगा यह जब आप रूम पे होम यहां पे
कहां गया भैया नॉलेज बेस पे चलते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां पर आप देखेंगे। अरे यार क्या हुआ भाई
यह?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम
हां
इस पे तो नहीं है। इसका दिखा नहीं रहा
यार। फ्री रूम है, पेड रूम है। यह फ्री
रूम है वैसे
बट यहां पर शो नहीं हो रहा है। ठीक है।
कोई बात नहीं है।
इट्स ओके। यह फ्री रूम है। चलो यहां शो
अभी देख लेना आप लोग। बट यह फ्री रूम है।
ठीक है? इसका यह पेड रूम नहीं है। तो यहां
पे जो आपका बेसिकली सर्च प्रोसेसिंग
लैंग्वेज होती है जिसके थ्रू आप क्वेरीज
को सर्च करते हो, क्वरीज डालते हो और सर्च
करते हो डेटा सेट्स के अंदर में। उस पे
बेस्ड यह रूम है। इस रूम को हां राइट। यह
प्रीमियम रूम नहीं है। फ्री रूम है। इस
रूम को आप सभी को बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट
है। आप सभी को मैंडेटरीली कंप्लीट करनी
है। इससे एग्जैक्टली आपको एसएल कैसे काम
करता है? सर्च प्रोसेसिंग लैंग्वेज क्या
होता है? ऑपरेटर्स उसमें कौन-कौन से होते
हैं? जैसे कि सर्च ऑपरेटर्स आप यहां पे
देखेंगे। तो देयर आर सर्च ऑपरेटर्स। जैसे
कि यहां पे नॉट इक्वल टू मैंने आपको बताया
इक्वल्स आ गया, लेस दैन है, लेस दैन और
इक्वल टू। रिसर्च ऑपरेटर्स कुछ होते हैं।
उनके बारे में आपको पता चल जाएगा। कैसे
लाइक रिजल्ट्स को फिल्टर करते हैं। तो
फिल्टरिंग के आपके यहां पे आपको ऑप्शंस
मिलेंगे। अलग-अलग फिल्टरिंग के अं
एग्जांपल्स मिलेंगे। फिल्टरिंग के आपको
यहां पे ऑपरेटर्स मिलेंगे वो आपको पता चल
जाएगा। ट्रांसफॉर्म करने के कमांड्स
मिलेंगे। लाइक किस तरीके से ट्रांसफॉर्म
किए जाते हैं। लाइक कमांड्स हैं। जैसे टॉप
है, रेयर है। तो ये सारी चीज़ है। अब टॉप
क्या करता है? रिटर्न्स द 10 मोस्ट
फ्रीक्वेंट वैल्यूज़ ऑफ़ द फील्ड
स्पेसिफाइड। तो मतलब कि जैसे आप इंडेक्स
Windows lock इंडज़ इंडज़ Windows log को
इंगेस किया। अब टॉप कमांड लिया यूजर लिमिट
इज़ इक्वल टू फाइव। तो जो भी आपने कमांड
डाला है उसको यहां पे क्या किया है? टॉप
10 के 10 मोस्ट फ्रीक्वेंट जो वैल्यू्यूज
है उसको निकाल के आपके सामने लाता है।
उसको आप लिमिट के थ्रू सेट भी कर सकते
हैं। लिमिट लाइक कितने पांच या 10 जो भी
लिमिट लगा रहे हैं। उसी तरीके से यहां पे
कुछ कमांड्स हैं जो आपको
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
देखने को मिलेंगे। ठीक है?
ओके। उसके बाद यहां पे ठीक है। अ उसके बाद
यहां पे स्ट्रक्चरिंग रिजल्ट्स को कैसे
स्ट्रक्चरिंग होती करनी है वो सारी चीजें
आपको जानने को मिलेंगी। ये सारी चीजें
आपको देख जानने को मिलेगा। तो यह जो लैब
है Splunk एक्सप्लोरिंग SPL यह आप लोग
कहीं लिख लीजिए या दिमाग में डाल लीजिए।
यह जब आप स्प्लक का द बेसिक्स प्रीमियम
रूम जो है इसके कंक्लूजन में आपको यहां पे
लिंक इसको मिल जाएगी। या तो आप ट्राईमी पे
डायरेक्ट सर्च भी कर सकते हैं। स्प्लंक
रिलेटेड आप मेनली जैसे मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं।
स्प्लक ट्रक में डैशबोर्ड पे जाएंगे। यहां
पे लर्न पे चलते हैं। यहां पे लर्न पे
चलके
पाथ पर करते हैं। एंड मॉड्यूल्स पर या
मॉड्यूल्स पर भी चल सकते हैं। यहां पर आप
प्लंक सर्च करते हैं। अच्छा पाथ नहीं इसका
मॉड्यूल है शायद। मॉड्यूल में आ जाएगा
आपको मिल जाएगी।
आई थिंक या तो वॉक थ्रू में मिल जाएगा।
मॉड्यूल में नहीं है। एडवांस स्प्ल है।
वॉक थ्रू में चलिए। हां स्प्लंक यहां पे
शायद मिल जाएगा। हां। वॉक थ्रू का है
पार्ट। तो वॉक थ्रू में आप आइएगा। स्प्लंक
सर्च कीजिएगा। तो यहां पे द बेसिक्स वाला
तो आपका ये जो है वो है बट यहां पे
स्प्लंक
एक्सप्लोरिंग एसएल ये मीडियम वाली ये
एक्सप्लोरिंग एसl जो है इस वाले पार्ट को
आप ओपन कीजिएगा। ये फ्री रूम है। इसको
जरूर से जरूर कंप्लीट कीजिएगा और कंप्लीट
करके Lindin पे इससे आपने क्या-क्या सीखा?
की पॉइंट्स बना के और डिफ्रॉनिस को टैग कर
दीजिएगा। ठीक है? बस दैट्स इट।
इज इट नेसेसरी टू मेक प्रोजेक्ट टू गेट
जॉब एज एसओसी एल1 देखो प्रोजेक्ट आपको
बनाना है आप बना सकते हो प्रोजेक्ट हमेशा
एक अच्छी चीज होती है बट जरूरी नहीं अगर
आपके अंदर प्रॉपर स्किल्स हैं तो यू डोंट
नीड कोई दिक्कत नहीं है आप इंटरव्यू तक
पहुंचो बस दैट्स इट। ठीक है? तो ये जो
सारी चीजें आपको कर लेनी है। सभी से हो
जाएगा। यह टास्क एज अ टास्क मुझे सब बताइए
क्योंकि यह मैं बार-बार इसलिए बोल रहा हूं
कि दिस इज़ वेरीेंट टू कंप्लीट दिस रूम और
फ्री ऑफ़ कॉस्ट है। कोई पैसा नहीं लग रहा
है। तो आपको इसको पढ़ना है सारे टास्क को
और इसके रूम्स को और इसके टास्क को
कंप्लीट करना है। फ्लैग्स ढूंढ के डालने
हैं और इसको पूरा कंप्लीट करना है। तो सभी
लोग कर लेंगे। मुझे पहले जल्दी से जल्दी
बताइए। फटाफट बताइए। देन
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इसको मैं टर्मिनेट कर देता हूं।
डन। आज ही कंप्लीट कर देंगे। क्या बात है।
अच्छी बात है। वेरी गुड अथर्व।
ठीक है। चलिए गुड।
ओके। तो ये आपका स्प्लंक का क्लियर हो गया
होगा। एक चीज और मैं आप सब से बोलूंगा कि
स्प्लंक का जो यह डॉक्यूमेंटेशन है
स्प्लंक की वेबसाइट पे जब आप स्प्लंक का
डॉक्यूमेंट स्प्ल की वेबसाइट पे जाएंगे तो
स्प्लक का यहां पे डॉक्यूमेंटेशन आपको
देखने को मिलेगा। ठीक है? कहां गया?
ये रहा डॉक्यूमेंटेशन। तो स्प्लन के
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन पे जाके आप बेसिकली अह
क्लाउड या एंटरप्राइज का जो भी
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन है तो आप डॉक्यूमेंटेशन को
जाके पढ़ सकते हैं। लाइक देयर आर लॉट ऑफ़
थिंग्स आपको सारी जानकारी यहां
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन में मिल जाती है। एंड बहुत
सारी चीजें जानने को मिलेगी। कैसे यूज़
करते हैं अगर आप चाहें तो आप देख सकते
हैं। थोड़ा और आपको इन डेप्थ जाना है।
दूसरी चीज कि ये स्प्लंक ऐसी चीज है। एक
ऐसी टॉपिक थी जिसको मैं अगर आपको पढ़ा के
बता रहा हूं तो मैंने तो आपको इस
स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में पूरा वो करके बताया।
बट यह ऐसी टॉपिक है जिसको आपको खुद से भी
हालांकि जितने भी टॉपिक्स मैं कराता हूं
ना आप खुद से अगर एक्सप्लोर नहीं कर रहे
हैं तो उसका कोई बेनिफिट नहीं है। तो आपको
खुद से भी इन टॉपिक्स को एक्सप्लोर करना
है। इन डेप्थ जाना है, समझना है और
प्रैक्टिस करनी है। तभी जाके आप एक्सपर्ट
बनेंगे। तभी जाके आप जॉब के लिए जॉब की के
लिए रेडी होंगे। ठीक है? तो आप प्लीज वो
काम करते रहिएगा। Lindin पे जरूर की
पॉइंट्स को टाइप लिखिएगा डे वाइज़ और
Lindin पे पोस्ट कीजिएगा। हमें टैग
कीजिएगा। लोगों को पता चलेगा। लोगों को
शेयर कीजिएगा वीडियो को। लोगों को भी इसका
आईडिया मिलेगा। ठीक है? दैट्स इट।
सर नेक्स्ट लेक्चर में Windows एंड
सिस्मोन लॉग्स भी अपलोड करके देखें क्या
प्लंक में? देख सकते हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं। Windows logs या कोई सा भी log smon
अभी तो एंड उसमें हम यूज़ करके देख ही सकते
हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। ठीक है?
फिलहाल के लिए अभी के लिए बस आज के सेशन
में स्प्लंक को हमने कंप्लीट किया है।
स्प्लंक हमने देखा है एग्जैक्टली कि
स्प्लंक एक्चुअली दिखती कैसे है? कुछ इस
तरीके की जैसे आपकी यहां पे आपको डैशबोर्ड
दिख रहा है। यह रियल स्प्लंक डैशबोर्ड है
जहां पे ये बुकमार्क्स आपके हैं। डैशबोर्ड
में यह आप होम डैशबोर्ड सेलेक्ट कर लीजिए
जो भी सेलेक्ट जैसे हमने वहां पे किया था।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो हमने यहां वहां पे अ कौन सा किया था?
फॉरवर्डर इंस्टेंस सेलेक्ट किया था। एंड
लिस्ट आपके तो ये फॉरवर्ड इंस्टेंस का
डैशबोर्ड यहां पे क्लिक यहां पे हो गया।
उसके बाद फॉरवर्डर डिसेबल्ड होता है बाय
डिफ़ॉल्ट। तो फॉरवॉर्डर को इनेबल आप कर
सकते हैं यहां से। तो यहां से इनेबल किए।
कितने देर के लिए इनेबल कर लिया। तो
फॉरवर्डर जो है इनेबल हो जाता है। जब ये
फॉरवर्ड इनेबल हो गए तो यहां पे जो है
डेटा सोर्सेस आनी शुरू हो जाती हैं। जो भी
लाइक व्हाटएवर यू हैव सेटअप वो आ जाता है
यहां पे। इसके अलावा आप डैशबोर्ड को चेंज
भी कर सकते हो। लाइक चेंज करना चाहते हो
चेंज कीजिए यहां पे। और यहां पे आप सीपीयू
रिलेटेड कोई अगर डैशबोर्ड
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] डालना चाहते हो।
जैसे CPU यूसेज या CPU इंस्टेंस यूसेज की
करना चाहते हो तो आपने CPU इंस्टेंस वाला
लगाया तो अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां पे CPU यूसेज का इंस्टेंस आपको पता
चल जाएगा। अब क्योंकि यहां पे अभी हमारा
लोकल मशीन है उसको हम यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो
ये हमारे लोकल मशीन का इंस्टेंस का
डिटेल्स यहां पे प्रोवाइड कर रहा है। जैसे
डेफोनिक्स पीसी यहां पे आपको दिख रहा
होगा। तो ये आपको डिटेल्स सारी प्रोवाइड
कर रहा है। किस तरीके की चीजें हैं यहां
पे ग्राफ्स के थ्रू आपको दिखा रहा है सारी
चीजें। तो अब यहां पे मेरे सिस्टम पे कोई
अटैक या कुछ ऐसा नहीं हो रहा ना। बट हां
इसको हम बाद में और भी डिटेल में कुछ और
चीजें भी हम देखने वाले हैं इसके अंदर
में। तो आपको और भी ज्यादा चीजें जो है
शायद क्लियर हो जाएंगी एंड यू विल गेट टू
नो। तो मैं यहां पे फिलहाल लॉग आउट कर
देता हूं। तो यहां पे फिर लॉग इन लॉग आउट
हो के फिर लॉग इन होगा। तो ये इस तरीके की
पूरी स्प्ल डैशबोर्ड थी। यह स्प्लक था
हमारा। आई होप कि आपको स्प्ल जो है समझ
में आया होगा। अगर फिर भी आपको थोड़ा लाइक
कंफ्यूजन हो कुछ हो तो आई रिक्वेस्ट यू टू
प्लीज रीवाच द वीडियो। आप इस क्लास को
वापस से देखिएगा। आपका और भी ज्यादा
क्लियर हो जाएगा। क्योंकि वापस से जब आप
देखेंगे ना तो आपको और क्लेरिटी मिलती है।
आपको दोबारा चीजें रिवाइज होती हैं और
आपको क्लेरिटी मिलता है और कमेंट्स जरूर
करिएगा क्योंकि कई लोग कमेंट नहीं कर रहे
हैं। 100 कमेंट्स का टारगेट बहुत बड़ी
टारगेट नहीं है। इतने लोग देखते हैं
मिनिमम एवरेज 2000 लोग देख रहे हैं डेली
बेसिस पे वीडियोस को। तो 100 कमेंट्स कर
दीजिएगा नेक्स्ट क्लास के लिए। नेक्स्ट
क्लास हम जल्दी लेकर आएंगे। एंड हमारे पास
अब ज्यादा टाइम नहीं है। यहां पे इन सेशंस
को कंप्लीट करेंगे। कुछ और टॉपिक्स हैं
उनको कंप्लीट करके हमारा ये सीरीज कंप्लीट
हो जाएगा। तो सीरीज कंप्लीशन में भी आई
डोंट थिंक ज्यादा टाइम है। एंड मैं कोशिश
करूंगा कि जुलाई के अंदर में ही पूरी
सीरीज कंप्लीट हो जाए। जुलाई जुलाई तक सब
कुछ कंप्लीट हो जाए। फाइनल हो जाए। मतलब
जुलाई मैक्सिमम मैं बोल रहा हूं। जुलाई इज
द मैक्सिमम आई एम सेइंग। बट आई विल ट्राई
कि वो जुलाई जुलाई में पूरा ही खत्म हो
जाए। सीरीज एंड हो जाए और उसके बाद हम
इंटरव्यू वाली चीजें शुरू कर दें। हम
सर्टिफिकेशन का मैंने सोचा है कुछ आपको
रियल कुछ सिनेरियो देके आपको वहां पे
प्रैक्टिस या हैंड्स ऑन कराना। अह एसओसी
का ट्राई कर रहे हैं सीटीएफ स्टाइल में
अपना खुद का कस्टम हमारा सीटीएफ वो भी हम
ट्राई कर रहे हैं वो भी हो जाए तो सारी
चीजें हम करेंगे बट धीरे-धीरे टाइम लगेगा
उसमें बट अभी ट्रेनिंग को हमें मेनली
हमारा मेन ऐ है कि ट्रेनिंग को टाइमली
कंप्लीट करना तो आई एम ट्राइंग टू कंप्लीट
इट बाय जुलाई एंड जुलाई जुलाई में खत्म।
सो गाइस अगर आपको ये वीडियो क्लासेस अच्छी
लगती है तो प्लीज एक रिक्वेस्ट है कि
प्लीज शेयर कीजिए। सबको शेयर कीजिए। जितने
लोग भी एंथूजियास्ट हैं एसओसी को लेके
एसओसी एल वन पोजीशन के लिए अप्लाई करना
चाहते हैं एसओसी के लिए प्रिपेयर कर रहे
हैं ब्लू टीमिंग के लिए प्रिपेयर कर रहे
हैं फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट में एक पेड ट्रेनिंग की
तरह आपको उसी क्वालिटी के साथ एक ट्रेनिंग
मिल रही है एंड आई होप कि आप उसको खुद तो
यूटिलाइज़ करेंगे ही करेंगे कर रहे हैं
दूसरों को भी मौका देंगे दूसरों के साथ भी
शेयर करेंगे दूसरों को भी आप सीखने में
हेल्प करेंगे क्योंकि वही सबसे बड़ी चीज
होती है नॉलेज शुड बी ओपन सोर्स एंड इट
शुड बी शेयरर्ड विथ एवरीबॉडी बिकॉज़ नॉलेज
को जब आप शेयर करते हैं तो आपकी खुद की भी
अपलिफ्टमेंट होती है। यह बात याद रखिएगा।
तो प्लीज डू शेयर द वीडियोस। ठीक है?
ठीक है हिमांशु। ओके भीमा थैंक यू वेरी
मच। यस रुद्र प्लीज रीवाच द वीडियो। ठीक
है। सो आई होप यू एंजॉयड द सेशन गाइस। दैट
वास ऑल फॉर टुडे एंड लेट्स गो टू द लाइव
इंटरेक्शंस हियर। चलिए यहां पे लाइव
इंटरेक्शंस [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] में
चलते हैं यहां पे। एंड टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट
एक बार देखते हैं। एज यूजुअल दीज़ आर द टॉप
फैंस लिस्ट। यहां पे भी नाम वही देखने को
मिल रहे हैं जो यूजुअली हमें देखने को
मिलते हैं। जनरली दे आर प्रेजेंट। ओके
ग्रेट। या सभी लोग ऑलमोस्ट हैं।
ओके। ओके एक दो लोग नहीं दिखे मुझे अभी
नहीं दिख गए दिख गए वो भी दिख गए ठीक है
चलिए अच्छी बात है अ ऑलमोस्ट सभी लोग यहां
पे प्रेजेंट ऑफेंस के लिस्ट में यहां पे
दैट्स ग्रेट एंड
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
नाउ इट्स टाइम टू एंड द सेशन आज की चलो
तुम तुम लोगों की कंप्लेंट होती है कि सर
बहुत लंबा सेशन लेते हो बहुत लंबा सेशन
चला जाता है देखो आज 1ढ़ घंटे की सेशन हुई
कम ही सेशन में निपटा दिया आज 1.5 आवर्स
में आपका सेशन एंड हो गया अदरवाइज कभी-कभी
तो 3-3 घंटे सेशन चली गई है राइट तो चलो
आज 1ढ़ घंटे में हो गया खुश हो जाओ आज तुम
लोग ठीक है
ओके
एक्स में डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल है सर्च
कर सकता है
ओके ओके श्योर सो मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास
में गाइस जाते-जाते लाइक ठोकते हुए चले
जाना सभी लोग सभी लोग एक लाइक ठोकना और
चले जाना ठीक है एंड देन 100 लाइक्स भी
ऑलमोस्ट हो चुके हैं थैंक यू वेरी मच एंड
अच्छा लगा आप में से कई लोग 50 लोग लगभग
लास्ट लास्ट तक थे काफी ज्यादा लोग लगभग
80 लोग भी आए थे आज सेशन के अंदर में। तो
अच्छा लगा। यू आर स्टिल कनेक्टेड टू द
सेशन टू दिस पर्टिकुलर ट्रेनिंग एंड इट इज़
रियली रियली इंटरेस्टिंग। सो जल्दी ही आप
में से जितने लोग भी एसओसी एल1 क्रैक
करेंगे जॉब। आई होप कि आप बताएंगे हमें
एंड Lindin पे पोस्ट करेंगे, हमें टैग भी
करेंगे एंड तब हमें एक्चुअल सक्सेस इस
सीरीज का समझ में आएगा कि हां एक्चुअली ये
सीरीज सक्सेसफुल हुआ है। तो चलिए मिलते
हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में। धन्यवाद सभी को।
गुड नाइट। शुभ रात्रि एंड टेक केयर
एवरीबॉडी।